раз О чудово колеги ради всіх вітати
Дякую вам що долучилися до нашого заходу
наживо чи знайшли таку можливість
враховуючи всі наші реалії складнощі
воєнного часу Отже раді вітати вас на
всеукраїнській конференції кар'єрний
тестування в дії Мене звати Роман я
керівник центру кар'єрів економії Тараса
Шевченка сьогодні буду вашому
модератором знову ж таки дякуючи засув
маємо нагоду зустрітися наживо бути в
цьому залі працювати в цьому залі і
будемо розпочинати наш конференції
Нагадую що у нас є і відео фотозйомка а
також є трансляція на Facebook для тих
учасників які долучаються до нас в
онлайн-формації і до вітального слова Я
запрошую пані Ірину Шумик генерального
директора директора та професійної
освіти так можна звісно
Добрий день шановні колеги перш за все
Вітаю тих героїв які не побоялися нічого
і приїхали сьогодні до нас сюди на
хмельниччину Славне місто
кам'янець-подільський і присутність
сьогодні з нами в залі ну і водночас я
вітаю наших колег тих хто знаходяться По
ту сторону екрану ми розуміємо що не так
все просто і не так все легко і знаємо і
про затримки потягів про відключення
світла але перш за все Я хочу вас всіх
привітати з тим що Ми продовжуємо жити
Що Ми продовжуємо працювати І що ми
максимально прагнемо до того щоби
Україна не зупинялась Щоб наша освіта
була дійсно якісна достойна відповідала
європейським стандартам І власне
сьогодні Ми піднімаємо такий важливий
для нас аспект це питання кар'єрного
консультування
можливим щоб Наші учні стали успішними в
своїй професійній кар'єрі і тому
сьогодні ми будемо максимально говорити
про те що таке кар'єрне консультування
чи потрібно воно закладом професійної
освіти в яких формах потрібно Ну і
загалом як привернути увагу молоді до
питання побудови своєї кар'єри я
надзвичайно Дякую господарям я дякую
Хмельниччині за те що рада нас до всіх
зустрічає приймає гарним сонячним днем
посмішками і хорошим настроєм тому всіх
Ще раз вітаю І всім гарного
продуктивного дня Так дякую дуже пані
Ірина І дійсно дуже дякуємо господарям
за чудову прийом за чудові умови для
нашої спільної ефективної роботи
впродовж сьогоднішнього дня і власне
хотілось би зараз до вітального слова
запросити представників Хмельниччини а
саме дарію Басюк директора Департаменту
освіти науки молоді та спорту
Хмельницької державної адміністрації тож
дає для вас слово вам і Дякую що
приймаєте нас на Хмельниччині
Шановні колеги ви на благословенній
землі тому що незважаючи на війну Ви
відчуваєте що у нас Тихо Ви відчуваєте
що у нас є світло холодна гаряча вода
тепло і це дійсно один з кращих готелів
міста кам'янця-подільського а Кам'янець
Подільський - це надзвичайне місто це
туристична Перлина України яка займає
третє місце за кількістю пам'яток
архітектури після Києва і Львова Я би
хотіла декілька слів розказати про
освітнє середовище Хмельницької області
оскільки
думаю шановним колегам цікаво дізнатися
яким чином ми функціонуємо в період
війни Якщо говорити про заклади
професійно-технічної освіти То наразі їх
на Хмельниччині функціонує 26
що говорити про загальну кількість
закладів освіти матча на увазі дитячі
садочки загальну середню освіту перед
фаховою вищу і то кількість сягає понад
1200 закладів хочу сказати що
з перших днів війни усі наші заклади
освіти з 14 березня вийшли на очне
навчання вийшли на навчання спочатку за
дистанційною формою а потім ми доклали
всіх зусиль для того щоб закладу освіти
працювали очно
знову-таки дякуючи Богу тільки сім
закладів освіти у нас постраждало від
воєнних дій це три дитячих садочка і 4
школи і вони були буквально в
двотижневий термін відремонтовані і
знову введені в експлуатацію 1 вересня
для усіх було і як і для нас також було
складним але протягом літа працювали над
тим щоб кожен заклад освіти мав укриття
наразі 100% закладів
професійно-технічної освіти 100%
закладів фахової передвищої освіти і
100% закладів вищої освіти у нас
отримали дозвіл на очну
структурну форму навчання тобто І лише
по школам трошки нижчі відсоток це десь
порядка 85 ну по садочкам звичайно
ситуація складніша і зараз обласна
державна адміністрація і
керівники територіальних громад
керівники закладів продовжують роботу
над тим щоб
облаштовувати укриття все більш і більш
якісно і відповідно до тих викликів які
дає нам військовий час хочу сказати що
незважаючи на складну ситуацію наші
заклади професійно-технічної освіти
практично повністю виконали регіональний
державний замовлення якщо ми говоримо
про регіональне замовлення а тут хочу
подякувати нашому голові обласної
військово-адміністрації воно залишилося
у нас точно в тому самому обсязі як і в
попередньому році то воно виконано
98,2%. Якщо говорити про державне
замовлення то процент виконання - це
1993 відсотки і далі ми будемо працювати
над тим щоб розширювати перелік
спеціальностей модернізувати
матеріально-технічну базу і змісту
освіти спільно з методичним центром
Продовжуємо роботу над удосконаленням
навчально-методичного забезпечення над
професійним і кадровим зростанням
закладів професійно-технічної освіти
нещодавно у нас було проведено такий
семінар по
скажімо сучасному стану тих проектів які
були фінансовані за кошти єбр це 4
шикарних проекти з одним ви сьогодні
познайомитеся це класний навчальний
готель який зараз якраз будується в
кам'янці-подільському якщо Ну я так
сказала сьогодні познайомився Якщо буде
час звичайно от який майже 10 мільйонів
вартість проекту і цей готель уже
приймає переселенців І уже заробляє
кошти за кошт Також у нас реалізований
прекрасний проект по навчальної теплиці
і знову-таки вона незважаючи на проблеми
в енергопостачанні працює і у нас
готується фахівці якраз по
вирощуванню рослин ви закритих грунтах
ще є проекти які пов'язані з формуванням
навчально-практичних центрів таких є у
нас на території області 8 і сьогодні у
нас якраз буде семінар з директорами
професійно-технічних закладів освіти
тому що користуючись нагодою Вони хочуть
зустрітися з Іриною володимирівною і ці
навчально-практичні центри також дають
сучасну якісну професійну технічну
освіту звичайно В мене є велике
сподівання що у зв'язку з великим
інтересом
міжнародної спільноти до проблем України
до проблем освіти в Україні ми зможемо
реалізувати ще декілька таких проектів я
їх не хочу називати амбітними вони
мабуть навпаки дуже приземлені оскільки
вони спрямовані на те щоб забезпечити
нові професійні навички для наших
переселенців отут трошечки детальніше
оскільки цей ракурс на внутрішньо
переміщених осіб на переселенців він для
нас дуже важливий з перших днів війни
Через хмельниччину хлинули тисячі людей
це абсолютно зрозуміло і багато з вас
відчули на власному досвіді наскільки є
важкою ця ситуація полешити рідну
домівку Хмельниччина прийняла транзитом
понад півмільйона внутрішнього
переміщених осіб це люди які переїжджали
до Закарпаття до Львівщини дуже багато
переїжджало виїжджало взагалі за кордон
103 тисячі внутрішньо переміщених осіб
зараз розташовані на території області
Ну невелика частина з них понад 3000 це
ті хто проживають до нині у нас в
закладах освіти але ми зовсім на тоне
ремствуємо навпаки до нині намагаємося
створити максимальну комфортні умови це
і безкоштовне навчання і безкоштовне
харчування Ну ви знаєте що комунальні
послуги нам допомагає вирішити держава
тобто внутрішньо переміщені особи Ну
наскільки можемо настільки Стараємося
прийняти їх густину хочу сказати що саме
в цій важкі часи у нас виникла
інноваційна така освітня платформа яка
називається освітній хап Хмельниччини
після того вона була поширена ну це була
ініціатива Міністерства освіти і науки
України вона якось так получається
залетіла да на наш в нашу область ми це
все одразу підтримали оскільки і
психологічний консультування і вивчення
мови і навіть спілкування з
професіоналами воно завжди позитивно
впливає на багато
завдяки цьому освітньому хабу Ми
привчили багато переселенців актуальним
професіям таким я слюсар електрозва це
кухарі це швачки це лісоруби які
актуальні для нашої місцевості та багато
інших і зараз Ми продовжуємо цю
ініціативу завдяки підтримці про ООН
завдяки підтримці інших фондів і думаю
що це актуально як для тих хто Втратив
роботу на Хмельниччині так і
как бы внутрішньо переміщення особи яким
потрібна нова життєва траєкторія
потрібні нові навички Звичайно можна
перераховувати дуже багато того що
робиться для збройних сил України
закладими освіти Я завжди низько
вклоняюся керівникам які докладають ну
максимально зусиль це починаючи від
простого збирання коштів і випікання
пиріжків закінчуючи збиранням Дронів
остання наша акція це було
700 дощовиків плач палаток для збройних
сил України які ми відчули в триденний
зараз хлопці і дівчата варять буржуйки і
також плитують сітки Тобто всі заклади
освіти незважаючи на канікули відпустки
складні умови все рівно продовжують
крокувати і наближувати нашу таку довгу
очікувану перемогу тому от так от така
коротка ну якби характеристика коротка
інформація зріс стосовно того що у нас
зараз відбувається в системі
професійно-технічної освіти і освіти
Хмельниччини загалом але я хочу сказати
ще Ну щось таке позитивне і приємне тому
що всі Дякую дійсно що ви зробили таку
складну дорогу знайшли можливість
приїхати до міста кам'янця-подільського
на правду Це місто туристичне на правду
Це місто яке обрало своєї стратегією це
розвиток туризму це створення
максимально комфортних умов для місцевих
жителів і для гостей які вітають для
кам'янця-подільського
і е понад 220 пам'яток архітектури які
починаючи від стародавніх римлян
оскільки турецький міст який ви сьогодні
точно побачите був закладений ще
стародавніми римлянами і закінчуючи
польською імперію російської імперію ви
побачите весь цей мікс архітектур про
унікальність міста кам'янця-подільського
говорить наприклад те що тут є пам'ятник
який поєднує мусульманство і
християнство це містом пов'язано дуже
багато легенд і є як мінімум дві локації
де ви можете загадати бажання і вітаю
вас від імені голови Хмельницької
Обласної військової адміністрації Сергій
Гамалія від імені міського голови
Михайла посідка оскільки вони всі знають
що в нас проходить такі форум але ви
знаєте що військовий час очільники дуже
зайняті Хочу запросити вас на екскурсію
яку для вас кам’янчани уже підготували
тому прошу Так оперативно попрацювати ми
погодили вже це питання з організаторами
Сьогодні ми побачите старовинну фортецю
яка була закладена ще в 12 столітті де
були турки де були поляки де були
Російська імперія А зараз вона гостинно
приймає гостей турецький міст думаю
можливо і мінарет костел і все те чим
Славна Кам'янецька Хмельницька земля
щиро вас вітаю Дякуємо дуже
а Дякуємо дуже пані Дарія А за ваш
виступ за вашу плідну та ефективну
роботу Так і Дякуємо тим хто знову ж
таки хто долучається до нас в онлайн
форматі мені повідомили що трансляція
наша вже стартувала тому колеги Хто
слухає нас в онлайні будь ласка ставте
реакції пишіть коментарі щоб ми розуміли
що у нас із зв'язком Все теж Чудово А я
хотів би трошки розказати про проект в
рамках якого проводиться і ця
конференція і заходи це тренінги для
викладачів тренінги для учнів які ми
проводимо в закладах безпосередньо так
наживо в онлайн форматі загалом цей
проект підтримка кар'єрного
консультування професійно-професійного
технічної освіти і у фоскілс він
об'єднує 7 областей України це такі
пілотний проект який об'єднавт дійсно
несміливіші області включаючи
миколаївщину включаючи Запорізьку
область так і незважаючи ні на що
враховуючи всі наші реалії зберігаючи
всі бесполкові умови ми все одно
проводимо ці заходи так для того щоб
розвивати кар'єрний потенціал наших
учнів розвивати самі себе для того щоб
ще ефективніше працювати в контексті
кар'єрного консультування зокрема так і
цей проект об'єднав 21 заклад
професійної та професійно-технічної
освіти прямо станом на от уже зараз це
19 проведених заходів це більше 600
учасників охоплених - це дуже багато
зворотнього зв'язку які ми
організаторами Також опрацьовуємо для
того щоб робити ці заходи кращий мене
колись на майбутнє а вже щоразу з
наступним нашим візитом ще краще ми ще
ефективнішими ще ціннішими звісно віримо
в наші ЗСУ і те що наш захід повністю
спокійно пройде тут сьогодні так але у
випадку повітряної тривоги звісно ми
маємо перейти в укриття колеги тому
Дбаємо про себе і про свою безпеку також
Бо це є наш пріоритет а Ми продовжуємо
рухатися далі по порядку денному І
власне про порядок денний Що ми сьогодні
будемо робити а перш за все на нас чекає
кілька виступів від експертів яких ви
всі добре знаєте сьогодні
і в онлайн форматі з нами будуть
експерти після виступів буде Панельна
дискусія вона об'єднує дуже різних
фахівців і це як на мене чудово тому що
ми почуємо різні думки і викладачів і
навіть учнів і
організація які займаються дослідженнями
роботи з молоді тому дуже насичена нас
чекає дискусія з дуже різними думками А
після того попрацюємо саме разом тому що
послухати дійсно можна в інтернетх і так
далі і тому подібне але попрацювати
наживо разом поганерувати ідеї думає всі
погодяться набагато ефективніше саме
наживо Отже наживо ми попрацюємо у
форматі Word Cafe Ось така наша програма
звісно у нас будуть перерви звісно у нас
буде обід як уже повідомила пані Дарья
ще й будуть ці культурні певні аспекти
так тому
працюємо ефективно активно так і маємо
багато планів на цей чудовий день тож
рухаємося колеги далі І зараз
наступний наш виступ від пані Ірини
жумік і поговоримо дуже коротко Але
знову плідно результативно про
перезавантаження професійно-технічної
освіти в Україні і власне ті здобутки
які вже є на сьогоднішній момент про
плани на найближче майбутнє слово пані
Ірині
дякую ще раз вітаю Шановні колеги власне
Сьогодні тема в нас звичайно кар'єрне
консультування але користуючись нагодою
хочеться трошки розказати Чим живе на
сьогодні система професійно-технічної
освіти як ви і ми працюємо І власне що
відбувається і трошки розказати про наші
плани саме в питаннях системи розвитку
системи професійної орієнтації
кар'єрного консультування Ми сьогодні
трошки звузили наше спілкування і будемо
говорити так виключно так або
орієнтовано тільки про кар'єрне
консультування тому що
власне ми ще плануємо декілька таких
низку закладів які комплексно доповнюють
одне одного буде ще один такий
всеукраїнський семінар чи конференція чи
форум ми ще працюємо над його концепцією
власним присвячений вже тепер питанням
професійної орієнтації але сьогодні
говоримо про кар'єру Я не знаю Як у вас
А у мене раніше ще коли я була маленькою
слово кар'єра викликала якийсь такий
негативний присмак і Чомусь мені
здається що це наша радянське минуле
воно говорити про те що ти хочеш бути
успішним чогось досягати Перепрошую мати
підвищення по службі це були якось
соромно було неправильно так думати
навіть зухвало я би сказала і Мабуть
це і зараз відкладає на нас певний такий
відбиток тому ми сьогодні
перестаємо соромитися бути кар'єристами
в хорошому сенсі цього слова ми говоримо
про те що людина взагалі повинна думати
про те як її розвиватися в особистому
плані Тобто ми можемо говорити про
освіту про захоплення про хобі і так
само в кар'єрному плані тому що
на сьогодні в сучасному світі в сучасних
умовах не думати про кар'єру не думати
про те як в подальшому розвиватися
постійно це власне означає бути
приреченим і не мати успіху Ну і в тому
числі перепрошую не давати про свій
добробут ви мабуть помічаєте і в
принципі це дослідження всі попередні
показували а наскільки ж сьогодні
важливо бути гнучким на ринку праці так
як варто наскільки важливо володіти
навичками своєї присутності ми знаємо що
кар'єри бувають горизонтальні кар'єри
бувають вертикальні можна переходити з
однієї сфери в іншу От наприклад я десь
особисто проходила різні етапи як
приміщувалась в одній організації з
посади на посаду і займалася різними
питаннями так і навпаки от у мене коли
прийшла на роботу в Міністерство Я
вважаю що в мене була така вища сходинка
та в моєму кар'єрному зростанні і
Якщо говорити про це Я вважаю що нашим
слухачам професійної освіти надзвичайно
важливо оволодіти цими всеми навичками І
тому ми будемо говорити В наступні
декілька років Я впевнена і в подальшому
про кар'єру багато і ми будемо
максимально працювати над тим щоб
система професійної освіти мала все ж
таки в собі такі структурні системні
елементи які допомагатимуть нашим
здобувачам освіти бути
конкурентоздатними на ринку праці що
сьогодні залишається надзвичайно
важливим і саме тому декілька років тому
назад ми вже почали спільно з колегами
пані Сніжана тут теж з інститутом
професійно-технічної освіти теж думати
про
загалом
ідею створення на базі закладів центрів
кар'єри чи потрібні вони чи не потрібні
Так Ми всі маємо обмежені ресурси Так ми
поки що ще не внесли зміни бо це
пов'язано з лімітованим фінансуванням до
там типових штатних розписів В нас немає
окремих фахівців Які би це займалися але
те що ця робота повинна здійснюватись це
об'єктивно тому ми йдемо іншим шляхом Ми
обираємо для себе для нас працівників
системи профтехоти
опановувати нові навички так навички з
професійною орієнтування навички з
кар'єрного консультування і
те яке кількість на сьогодні закладів
вже умовно створили центр кар'єри я
відвідуючі бачила знаєте все починалося
з таких невеличких кабінетів десь
переобладнаних А зараз я вже бачу як
підхід змінюється Тобто ми розуміємо що
центр кар'єри має бути таким певним
хабом куди по-перше хочеться прийти Де
хочеться спілкуватися отримувати нову
інформацію обмінюватися Ну і звичайно де
досягати певних домовленостей з
партнерами тому що коли говорити про
саму кар'єру не думати про тих хто цю
кар'єру буде забезпечувати це власне
роботу давців та з тисків ми постійно
співпрацюємо дуже складно
про методики про інструменти ми будемо
говорити Сьогодні пізніше я повертаюсь
до своєї презентації
і хочу просто описати поточну ситуацію
на сьогодні за нашою інформацією за теми
даними які є перевірені тому що ми
прекрасно розуміємо що взяти Донецьку
Луганську область там Запорізьку область
не всюди ми маємо доступ до всю
інформацію ми знаємо 17 закладів
професійної освіти зруйновано повністю
114 мають певні пошкодження це досить
таке значний удар по системі закладів
тому що в нас трошки менше ніж 700
закладів на сьогодні в сфері і ми
розуміємо що сьома частина закладів
не зовсім є
придатною для власне функціонування
використання і багато закладів
знаходяться на території де власне
здійснюється бойові дії і
можливість переходу і використання
різних моделей роботи воно Звичайно є на
досить гострим питанням яку правильну
модель обрати але
ми як Міністерство освіти і науки завжди
всім нашим партнерам і для суспільства
говоримо що ми маємо три Перемоги перше
Нам вдалося з 1 вересня ефективно
організувати освітній процес і
надзвичайно приємно те що
Державна служба надзвичайних ситуацій і
Міністерство внутрішніх справ
відзначають що саме заклади професійної
освіти найкраще готові до організації
освітнього процесу в нас є облаштовані
так не всіх закладах але в переважній
більшості сховища в нас є можливість
організувати
якщо це потрібно навчання або
перебування наших учнів здобувачів
освіти в умовну безпечних
приміщеннях під час повітряних тривог ми
максимально намагаємося теж сприяти І
власне заклади профтехосвіти процес
включені до програми Міністерства освіти
з отримання ноутбуків як для вчителів
так І власне саме для закладів ще
завдяки програмі ufuse ми очікуємо
підтримку теж постачання комп'ютерної
техніки До закладів тому ми максимально
змінюємо акценти і все ж таки враховуючи
різні моделі організації роботи змішано
або дистанційно теж створюємо умови для
того щоб навчання було ефективним
нам за підтримки комітету
з питань освіти науки та інновації
Верховної Ради України теж вдалося
внести зміни до чинного закону про
професійну освіту і інших законодавчих
актів в частині того щоб
знаєте це питання
наприклад неможливості навчатися дітей з
інших регіонів в тій чи іншій області
або до прикладу з тим що людина яка
втратила
можливість працювати за своєю професією
або втратила робоче місце перемістилася
і потребує давайте відвертими взяти
місто Маріуполь і взяти місто
кам'янець-подільський тут немає
металургійних комбінатів люди
переміщуються їм треба десь працювати а
це означає що треба здобути нові навички
а це це означає що в таких скрутних
умовах Ми створюємо можливості для того
щоб ці навички були отримані нові
професії були здобуті і це теж на
сьогодні дозволяє наше чинне
законодавство більше того враховуючи
світовий тренд європейський тренд
запровадження Micro cradentions чи як ми
це будемо швидше за все в Україні
[музика]
називати мікрокваліфікаціями все ж таки
переходити на таке короткострокове
навчання здобуття десь якихось невеликих
за обсягом компетентностей і можливість
одразу
виходу на ринок праці Тобто ми тут так
само повертаємося до того що на ринку
праці потрібно бути гнучким питання
пошуку роботи питання співпраці
взаємодії з роботодавцем воно
залишається гострим А це все навички які
потрібні для побудови успішної кар'єри І
врешті нам теж вдалося залучити певну
підтримку від посольства Німеччини від
власне наших інших партнерів від
європейського інвестиційного банку і ми
нашу мрію по створенню центрів
професійної досконалості ми її не
Залишаємо ми дивимося в майбутнє з
великими надіями і крок за кроком
наближаємося до того що скоро всі в
Україну поїдуть вивчати досвід як же
треба навчатися професіям Ну і декілька
таких теж таких загальних фактів Вони
можливо будуть трошки нудні тому що ми
говоримо документи про якісь регуляції
бо ще чим займається
Міністерство власне нами було
затверджено тоді так екстрене положення
про внутрішню академічну мобільність і
за даними нашими в минулому році ним
скористалися 315 осіб принаймні було
врегульовано питання перебування дітей
які переміщені також внесено зміни до
типових правил прийому і ми зараз
працюємо над електронним модулем для
вступу до закладів професійної освіти
Тобто ми диджиталізуємося цифровізуємося
і в подальшому сподіваємося це теж так
само спростить роботу як закладами
освіти так і нашим здобувачам не треба
буде можливо приходити можна буде подати
заявку через електронний кабінет
ми власне поки що тестуємо і можливо
хтось з тих хто присутній сьогодні в
залі або знаходяться По ту сторону
екрану беруть участь у навчанні там за
виднокурсом або
наша ще одна курс з громадянської освіти
і тестують зараз платформу там вона така
це власне аналог платформи всеукраїнська
школа онлайн Але це буде платформа саме
для системи професійної освіти там буде
можливість навчатися як здобувачам
освіти
педагогам системи професійної освіти бо
ми там передбачаємо низку курсів для
підвищення кваліфікації і так само
будь-кому бо ми хочемо зробити короткі
курси Ми хочемо робити різноманітні
воркшопи наприклад А чому б нам не
зробити з Євгеном клопотенком workshop
про те як випекти брауні так можна можна
всім буде цікаво і всі це можуть
користуватися тому ідеї про запуски
розвиток платформи У нас теж багато і ми
сподіваємося що ось-ось вона вже буде
презентована на Широкий загал з тим
функціоналом який є можливий власне
є внесено зміни Якщо раніше в системі
професійної освіти не було поняття
міжнародної педагогічної мобільності
тепер така можливість є
відповідні зміни є виписана процедура це
можливо не класична Академічна
мобільність яку ми маємо в системі вищої
освіти але можна укладати різноманітні
договори їздити за обміном І власне
робити максимально те що
покращить
навички і знання здобувачів освіти і
підвищить якість освіти
також
власне
продовжуємо ми децентралізацію і
зрозуміло зараз під час воєнних дій
трошки ускладнено Ця історія все з
документами підписаннями але ми все ж
таки не спиняємося на цьому
на цьому напрямку і максимально
намагаємося напрацювати в тому числі і
методичній рекомендації для побудови
оптимальної мережі вже на регіональному
рівні
Я сьогодні ще покажу трошки згодом дві
наші промоційні кампанії приклади руку
до і все працює завдяки нам тому що
неодноразово Ми всі з вами говорили про
те що Імідж професійної освіти в
суспільстві ну відверто скажімо не
досить високий і чомусь сприйняття
професії та інженера і професії майстра
з монтажу сантехнічних приладів Та вона
різна хоча Насправді Я пишаюся нашими
сантехніками якщо хтось слідкує за
нашими новинами троє наших хлопців
поїхали правда поза конкурсну але зараз
завершили свою участь у Німеччині у
змаганнях World Skills І показали там
досить гідний рівень і можна вивчити
наскільки Ця професія є поважною в
Європі
високооплачуваною і я би сказала що в
нас і зараз уже на професію сантехніків
в окремих регіонах є конкурс
Так
звісно освіти я казала що буде трошки
нудно Тобто ми виписуємо компетентності
змінюємо стандарти зараз ще будемо
переходити на
Я вже нашу методистом кажу ми не будемо
робити це тут і зараз одномоментно що
завтра всі переходимо на модульні
програми Ні ми з вами навчимося їх
писати правильно складати правильно для
того щоб нам було зручно цим
користуватися для того щоб ми могли
перезараховувати результати навчання як
і з іншими складниками освіти наприклад
чому би окремі модулі здобуті в системі
профтехосвіти не можуть бути зараховані
в системі фахової перевищують чи вищої
освіти для того щоб співставляти
отримані результати навчання якщо хтось
із наших учнів наприклад півроку
провчиться за кордоном повернеться і нам
треба його оцінити і продовжити тому
власне цю роботу теж продовжується я
щиро дякую всім нашим методичним службам
які активно і закладами освіти і
роботодавцем які активно до цього
процесу долучені Також ми
спільно з партнерами І за це їм окремо
подяка
організували в декількох областях курси
для внутрішнього переміщених осіб власне
для тих хто Втратив роботу або
взагалі
перемістився можливо і не був ніколи в
системі професійної освіти але на
сьогодні потребує нових навичок для
започаткування власної справи Чому ні
можна вивчитися на
кравця чи там можна сказати
жвачку і купити собі машинку вже
починати самому працювати Це Це
абсолютно логічно і це можливо
в нас врегульовано було питання видачі
документів про професійну освіту
державного зразка це було дуже гостро
питання для тих регіонів які є на
сьогодні тимчасово окупованими і Ми
продовжуємо навчання педагогів Тобто ми
дбаємо не тільки про розвиток навичок
наших здобувачів освіти і про педагогів
в нас були там окремі курси
по проектному менеджменту теж Ми трошки
по цифровим зараз запустили видно курс
по промоції тобто максимально
намагаємося пропонувати такі актуальні
на сьогодні навички Ну і власне Я хочу
зараз трошки розказати про інформаційну
кампанію яку ми запустили
оскільки вона теж покликана на те щоб
зламати певні стереотипи або
кар'єра вона нерозривно пов'язана з
професією так ну стою чи іншою ми можемо
змінювати звичайну професію але все одно
кар'єрне зростання відбувається в рамках
тої чи іншої професії і нам на сьогодні
є надзвичайно важливим щоб всі професії
в Україні є це так кажу були популярними
були за були затребуваними і власне
викликали велику повагу
серед нашого суспільства Ми не можемо
одночасно ухопити всі професії тому в
наш фокус потрапили 8 і на
сайті мон цієї ролики вони відеоролики
вони є зараз в доступі Ми багато про них
писали Ми публікували вони були також
розміщені в YouTube в Інстаграмі в Тік
тоці Перепрошую Тому що нас Діти
дивляться саме там і вони сьогодні в
основному бувають там я навіть сама
щовечора туди ходжу для позитиву і
гарного настрою тому ми максимально
намагалися охопити через різні канали
нашою компанією великою інформаційною
кампанією Ну я думаю що всі бачили я тут
так просто для
відео покажу це наш проморолік вісім
історій молодих людей і трошки постарші
людей про те як вони обирали свою
професію про те як вони інколи
помилялися з вибором професії Я
наприклад не соромлюся сказати мій вибір
був помилковий коли я взяв собі там
16-17 років вирішила що я піду
економістом ну це таке було трошки
порада від батьків трошки мода в
суспільстві і ніхто Мені тоді не
підказав пройти якийсь профорієнтаційний
тест чи придумати яким я все ж таки хочу
бути отримані знання мені завжди ставали
в нагоді це не така професія яка там я
скажу що в нас здобута можливо не зовсім
актуально але в процесі професійної
діяльності Я зрозуміла вже чим я хочу
займатися що мені є близько де я
найкраще розкриваюся і мені довелося
перевчитися
І знаєте ніхто не каже що це погано Так
Тобто там помилятися ну це там пластиво
Але
в цей момент був втрачений мабуть мій
найголовніший ресурс якого ніколи не
повернути і який найдорожчий у будь-якої
людини у будь-якої людини це час тобто
це основна задача це ефективно
використовувати наш найдорожчий ресурс
цей час тому і ми з вами будемо
напрацьовувати різні методики Як
профорієнтацію так і про консультування
щоб допомогти і Нам самим і нашим
здобувачам ефективно його
використовувати наша інформаційна
кампанія має назву все працює завдяки
нам в рамках цієї компанії є відповідний
сайт де розміщені ці ролики де можна
зробити наприклад свій стікер де можна
прочитати про Ці професії де навіть
зазначено середній рівень заробітних
плат Тобто ми максимально так в простій
зрозумілій всім формі на лендингу на
сторінці все працює завдяки нам
англійською мовою
теніс туас називається завдяки нам і Ми
запрошуємо хто ще не бачив будь ласка
передивіться і використовуйте вони
абсолютно відкриті ними можна
користуватися ось Мої колеги та за
статистикою кажуть що ми маємо понад 1
мільйон переглядів в YouTube і це досить
непоганий показник Я сподіваюся що
дійсно ця реклама запам'яталася багатьом
ми розіслали постери відповідні рекламні
по закладах освіти пішли на департаменти
розподілені між закладами освіти які ви
теж можете використовувати були
розміщені влітку в мене теж колективом
на фоні деяких постерів на Хрещатику
фотографувались наприклад з цією
рекламою Я знаю що вони були точно в
регіонах Ну і звичайно реклама в
Instagram і Facebook
але один раз запустити промо компанію ну
це це добре звичайно але якщо говорити
про якісні зміни суспільного сприйняття
цього мало тому ми вже думаємо про
наступну шукаємо можливості шукаємо
партнерів тому що цю роботу треба
продовжувати про нас Треба говорити Я
погоджуюся з моєю колегою подругою
Оленою колесніковою яка від роботодавців
яка весь час кажуть Ну чому ви весь час
говоримо що в нас щось в системі освіти
погано тобто щоб ми де би ми не
виступали ми завжди говоримо про те що в
нас погано нас Не тільки погано ну В нас
є звичайно проблеми це нормально мати
проблеми але ми маємо дуже багато
позитивних якісних прикладів і
якщо повертатись до комунікаційної
компанії минулого в грудня яка
називалася ми змінюємося тобто ми дійсно
почали змінюватися 16-го року хтось
трошки раніше але так знаєте потужно
16-го року і про те що ми змінюємося Нам
треба говорити говорити якісно багато з
усіма І власне одна із функцій центрів
кар'єри в закладах освіти це теж є певна
промоція закладу промоції перед
роботодавцями промоції перед майбутніми
абітурієнтами Ну і друга компанія яку ми
зробили це така коротенька маленька і
дуже така точкова кампанія
інформаційна приклади руку до
на сьогодні цей теж
який меседж та таке повідомлення яке Ми
хочемо донести до
суспільства вони є дуже важливим
здобуваючи професію стаючи професіоналом
ми всі прикладаємо руку до багато чого
До надзвичайно важливих речей щоденних
свіже зварене кава свіже випечений хліб
відремонтований кран це все те що
створює для нас якісне життя та
комфортне життя а відремонтований
автівки
пошиті бронежилети і таке інше вони
наближають власне нас до перемоги і ми
говоримо про те що кожен з нас може
прикласти руку до відбудови країни до
перемоги і до розвитку країни це це
кожен обирає свій шлях і в нас теж в цій
інформаційній компанії було декілька
відео
були інфографіки і я скажу Так не знаю
мені буде цікаво сьогодні от в наших вже
такому неформальному спілкуванні за
кавою почути від вас відгук А чи
візуально наприклад Ця компанія
візуальний стиль цієї кампанії він вам
прийнятний чи він подобається як його
сприймає молодь тому що коли ми
пропрацьовували його і ми вдячні нашим
партнерам прожектори які допомогли нам з
цим ми ґрунтувалися не просто так би нам
це подобається ми проводили фокус-групи
ми опитували і ми намагалися обрати саме
той візуальний стиль так він
нестандартний тут немає шестеронок тут
немає чогось такого до чого ми звикли
зазвичай впроктах освіті важкого мало
там не знаю що там може бути якісь ключі
та щось там десь кастрюльки там все
решта та комбайни але ми власне говоримо
тут більше про людину про наші
можливості про наші прагнення і ми
кажемо що ось ми про втех
ми відкриті ми готові вам допомогти
реалізувати ваші бажання ваші таланти
ось власне це так сьогодні все що я би
хотіла розказати про систему
профосвіти так важко так не просто але
ви всі герої і вам низький оклі Не
величезна подяка ми цього року прийняли
на навчання більше 80 тисяч учнів
нехай це не 200 тисяч і в нас поки що
немає черги до закладів Ну хіба щодо
окремих але це означає що сфера живе і
що в Україні дійсно є Ті хто хочуть
здобувати професії бути гарними
фахівцями і крокуємо вперед працюємо над
тим щоб наші заклади були популярними
новими інноваційними і розвиненими
Так я тоді романи Вам мабуть передаю
слово я думаю що нам тепер вже час
перейти до практичних
власне там таких теоретичних і
практичних засад кар'єрного
консультування Дякую Так Дякуємо дуже
пані Ірини за виступ а дійсно бачимо що
роботи не просто багато а багато чого
вже робиться ми як і всі Українці не
зупиняємося працювати знову ж таки
створювати нові можливості нові формати
для того щоб професійна освіта ставала
ще популярнішою немає необхідності
казати що затребувані що є тому що
враховуючи наші реалії війни так попит
запит від держави від приватних установ
точно є Так ми маємо готувати фахівців
які власне будуть професіоналами цієї
своєї справи кожен на своєму місці як
кажуть так і дійсно переходимо вже про
те щоб поговорити А що саме є кар'єрне
консультування яке його аспекти можливо
які відмінності від інших форматів чому
це важливо для центрів кар'єри в тому
числі які вже функціонують на базі
закладів
професійно-професійно-технічного світу
або ж створюються так то про це ми
будемо говорити з з паном Тарасом
деркачем керівником платформи кар'єр-хаб
го центр розвиток корпоративного
соціальної відповідальності пане Тарасе
чи чуєте нас пам'ятає зустріч з Тарасом
чую пам'ятаю зустріч з вами на
конференції Future of Work ради почутися
в онлайні так тож бачимо вже на екрані
бачимо трансляції тож пане Тарасе вам
слово отже що таке керівник
консультування які його головні аспекти
прошу вас
колеги Всім доброго дня радий вас бачити
радий що вдалося приєднатися попри
відключення світла по Україні але
сьогодні
важливий день Сьогодні ми говоримо про
те що таке кар'єрне консультування
навіщо воно потрібне і навіщо його
впроваджувати в закладах
професійно-технічної освіти професійної
освіти і
розпочну я власне
такого невеличкого знайомства Мене звати
Тарас Деркач вже представили я опікуюся
платформою кар'єр Hub це експертна
платформа центру розвиток корпоративної
соціальної відповідальності ми
розвиваємо програму мрії мотодіємо це
програма для підтримки молоді і якраз
займаємося питаннями кар'єрного
консультування займаємося безпосередньо
допомогою молоді в обранні професійної
кар'єри або допомагаємо
працевлаштуватися розвинути м'які або
професійні навички
робимо це у підтримці
Міністерства освіти Міністерство молоді
та спорту і також наших партнерів із
USA та організації Айс Ну і Якщо
говорити про наш досвід ми маємо вже
великий досвід саме з розробки програм
кар'єрного консультування розробили
першу україномовну програму навчання
кар'єрних консультантів і розпочали
відтоді це було ще 2019 році розпочали
впровадження питання кар'єрного
консультування також у молодіжних
центрах і
в закладах освіти побачили також деякі
відмінності щодо власних кар'єрного
консультування такого більш
[музика]
практикувальну роботу і того яке
відбувається в закладі освіти коли ну
практично немає можливості виділити
достатньо багато часу приділити їх
одному студенту і доводиться власне
влаштовувати масові заходи групи в
кар'єрне консультування і надавати більш
такі широкі кар'єрні послуги для молоді
Отож сьогодні трішки поговоримо про
те чому це важливо і які власне основи
да кар'єрного консультування що це таке
які з ним працювати
Якщо говорити про актуальні виклики на
ринку праці можна ще брати спочатку 2001
е-е
2021 року ми говоримо про те що при
виборі професії молоді люди дійсно часто
керуються стереотипами Я думаю що це
така доволі відома
відома статистика І власне Ключовим
фактором вибору професії все ж таки
ключовим стимулом є батьки саме тому
важливо допомагати молоді саме
самовизначенням да допомагати їм
приймати зважене рішення тому що І
батьки в тому числі не мають якихось
інструментів для прийняття зваженого
рішення Якщо говорити про молодь то
переважно більшість молоді дійсно
зазначає що відчуває потребу у знаній
про різноманітний кар'єрні можливості
про те як розвивати кар'єру як шукати
роботу
і вже звісно спочатку повномасштабного
вторгнення змінився пріоритет І власне
на ринку праці вийшла наперед з ті
важливі для економіки країни сектори
деякі деякі сектори зараз дуже сильно
потребують
молодих людей і власне зроста треба у
фахівцях зокрема стем стем з професій
так іт-фахівці в інженерів агрономів
робітників виробничої сфери в тому числі
які готують заклади профтехоти Ну і
звичайно це все
створює у
абітурієнта або в студентах якщо ми
говоримо вже про два буде
категорія
таку плутанину Так Вони намагаються
обрати професію але не знають на що
опиратися і не знають як дійти до вас
так довачів освіти
власне усвідомлено Не і зберегти цю
мотивацію для навчання зберегти
усвідомлення що їм потрібно яка їхня
мета як отримати професію власне потім
себе реалізувати мені і таким чином
ми
бачимо що кар'єрне консультування дає
можливість власне опинитися на Землі на
опинитися на цій мовно дорозі
певним чином
виходити з тих можливостей із тих
талантів інтересів людини які у неї вже
є зараз
поставити певну кар'єрну мету і власне
прокласти шлях до цієї мети
ну а для максимального розуміння важливо
дати також не лише як сказати рибу але і
вудочку тобто дати певні навички і які
допоможуть власне орієнтуватися
в кар'єрному на ринку праці да мати
певні кар'єрні навички для того щоб
власне рухатися до цієї мети
або ставити нову І от якщо ми говоримо
про кар'єрне консультування переходимо
вже власне до відповіді на Основне
питання кар'єрний консультування якщо
Дуже просто Це такий певний
організований процес
який допомагає в нашому випадку
здобувачам освіти у розкритті їхнього
кар'єрного потенціалу
побудові певний стратегії розвитку у
супроводі до
підготовці до працевлаштування або в
прямому безпосередньо у процесі
отримання бажаної посади коли молода
людина наприклад йде на стажування з нею
працюють кар'єр працює кар'єрний
консультант для того щоб допомогти їй
закріпитися пройти і випробувальний
термін і так далі Якщо говорити про мету
то власне те що я казав це не лише
допомога молоді вихваленню якогось
рішення так або там зрозуміти що для неї
важливо яку професію обрати або
вибрати роботу Так це також і розвиток
цих навичок розвиток навичок які
допоможуть їй самостійно ухвалювати це
рішення в майбутнє
Ну і звичайно
важливо робити як індивідуа
льним мені консультування так і груповим
якщо ми говоримо про напрямок кар'єрного
консультування Мабуть це найбільш дасть
можливість зрозуміти які є власне
напрями в першу чергу це профорієнтація
так знайома вам яка важлива для закладів
профтехосвіти на етапі якраз коли йде
вступна кампанія коли ми говоримо Ми
працюємо собі клієнтами і намагаємося
зрозуміти дати їм можливості розібратися
з тими напрямами так які існують у
вашому закладі
щоб вони могли обрати професію І власне
обрати напрям навчання у вашому закладі
якщо говорити про інші
етнічні напрями кар'єрного
консультування це також питання
працевлаштування Так коли вже
здобувач завершує навчання і хоче пройти
стажування або піти на роботу відповідно
для цього потрібно сприяння там у
підготовці резюме підготовці до
співбесіди і так далі це може бути також
розвиток кар'єри це коли молода людина
вже працює і вона має розуміти як
розвивати цю кар'єру вертикально тобто
зростати як управління як менеджер чи
горизонтальна тобто розвивати професійні
навички зростати у вартості да як як
фахівець це також кар'єрне
консультування це також про кар'єрні
кризи тобто коли Зараз ми більшість із
нас відчуваємо такі переживання через
або через втрату роботи або через
загрози для нашої безпеки відповідно
відчувається вигорання
відчувається втрата сенсів у роботі
тобто Навіщо мені працювати якщо я там
або немає можливості або мені Занадто
сильно для цього треба там старатися А я
можу пробити щось набагато простіше І
власне це також є предметом роботи
кар'єрного консультанта аби виходити з
цих країн аби допомагати молоді з цим
боротися Ну і звичайно це старт бізнесу
тобто окремий напрям - це допомога
молоді і власне будувати свою кар'єру як
самозайнята особа або фізична особа
підприємець або власне відкрити свій
свою справу повноцінну набрати
співробітників починати працювати власне
ці
консультування
можна ми можемо виділити окремо
профорієнтаційне консультування і якщо
говорити по етапно тому що ми можемо
знаєте вибрати багато різних підходів
але найбільше узагальнений і більш
практичний це власне підхід коли ми
починаємо зі певного знайомства
уточнення запиту Коли це може бути до
речі в груповій роботі також тобто
можете розглядати це як в
індивідуальному форматі так і в
груповому тобто знайомство наприклад з
групою група абітурієнтів
ми проводимо інтерв'ю і збір інформації
Тобто запитуємо чим цікавиться дитина
які в неї є інтереси які в неї є запити
або питання да чого вона хотіла
дізнатися далі важливим інструментом є
профорієнтаційне тестування воно бачите
тут є лише одним із етапів воно не
заміняє повністю профорієнтацію це лише
такий інструмент який допомагає
той чи інший збір інформації так
підсилити оцю діагностику після цього
йде
обговорення тобто неможливо просто
Пройти тестування і отримати просто як
на ЗНО свій бал і піти щасливим можливо
також щоб зрозуміти що це означає для
людини тому важливо обговорення і
підготовка певних рекомендацій Так зараз
результатами цього тестування І власне
інтерв'ю
після цього іде вже тестування обраної
професії тобто по суті це ті ж самі
зустрічі з фахівцями це можливо
екскурсії на підприємство або екскурсії
до вас у заклади для того щоб подивитися
як працює так і які можливо є технічні
можливості да для того чи іншого фахівця
і як в якому середовищі буде він
працювати так або з якими інструментами
з якими технологіями Ну і звичайно це
вже створення кар'єрного плану на сам
кінець Коли
молода людина розуміє
яка в чому суть професії які власне
тестування до речі може стосуватися
кількох професії або кількох напрямів і
після цього створення кар'єрного плану
вже сфокусовано напевно конкретну мету
дуже часто Ось ці
під час заходів ми пропускаємо цей
внутрішній
внутрішній блок де ми одразу наприклад
знайомимося і одразу пропонуємо що ми
маємо В нашому закладі Але якщо ми
включимо туди в цю профорієнтаційну
роботу ще і спілкування про інтереси
підлітків про інтереси наших
абітурієнтів або також певне тестування
або обговорення певних
переваг чи недоліків тої чи іншої
професії то це посилить мотивацію
молодої людини для обрання і подальшого
тестування і подальшого знайомства з
цими професіями
Якщо ж казати про
методики то тут це тут лише деякі
методики які можна використовувати
ключовим
проференція
оце діагностика це той перший етап яким
третій вірніше етап які ми називали
тести Фактично це різноманітні методики
не завжди вони пов'язані з відповідями
на питання якогось тесту це можуть бути
просто роздуми про наприклад техніка
антитіл про те чого мені не хочеться да
тобто молода людина йде і ви навіть як
консультант та із для абітурієнта можете
сказати що от давай виберемо серед наших
професій Да скажи як чого б ти не хотів
робити да вони хотіли і людина
відповідно іде до тої професії або до
тої до того рішення яке є для найважливе
від протилежного і що говорити про інші
тестові методики Це звісно тестування з
класичним відповім на питання і
відповідно певним зворотнім зв'язком
щодо там Типу особистості щодо рівня
мотивації до тих чи інших напрямів Ну і
звичайно є слот-аналіз це як уже більш
такий комплексний інструмент так який
може бути взагалі основою для вашого
для дослідження молодої людини самої
себе тобто визначені і сильних сторін
визначення тих
зон розвитку ідеї потрібно ще більше да
отримувати знаючи такі знань і фактично
врахування певних зовнішніх факторів
тобто які можливості є на ринку праці да
які можливості є у вашому закладі
якщо казати про тепер про класичне
кар'єрне консультування так тому що
кар'єрне консультування Це трошки більше
Да трошки ширше ніж
безпосередньо там профорієнтація чи
там допомога з працевлаштуванням то
даємо такі 5 етапів вони доволі
інтуїтивні тобто на початку це певне
налагодження контакту так як і от по
аналогії з профорієнтацією ми говорили
запит так тобто домовленість про те що
хоче отримати в результаті ця людина
далі аналіз тобто проведення от
різноманітного тестування діагностика
опитування
Можливо там створення якихось схем щодо
того як може розвиватися кар'єра людини
далі це оцінка ресурсів тобто розуміти
що уже є в людини для досягнення цілей
чи готова вона діяти які в неї є
можливості відкриті і після цього
прийняття певного рішення да тобто
вибір якогось рішення бачите тут
важливого немає етапу тестування
професій тому що це не йде про Ну тут є
універсальна модель та тут не йде мова
про профорієнтацію тому тут немає Ось
цього етапу тестування професій тобто
знайомства заглиблення в неї тут є
власне прийняття рішення одразу і
нарешті розширення тобто коли ви вже
прийняли рішення і Йдете у певну певному
напрямку наприклад обрали якусь вакансію
так І ви вже починаєте в ній розвиватися
і для цього вам потрібно підтримка да
підтримка кар'єрного консультанта якщо
доволі
в загальному можна назвати такі формати
групових
заходів кар'єрного консультування перше
в першу чергу це
групова консультація зрозуміло що
Оскільки у вас може бути багато великої
кількість так студентів здобувачів Ви
маєте з ними працювати відповідно групою
і ось кар'єрного консультування ви
можете фактично або поєднувати і
транслювати на цілу групу тобто
Але бажано обирати певну тему тобто якщо
тема наприклад підготовка до
вибір програми стажування то ви про цю
на цю тематику і говорите так і
розмовляєте з ними про це бажано давати
невеличку теоретичну частину да тобто
розказувати які програми існують
наприклад далі обговорювати з ними
наприклад критерії вибору так той чи
інший програмі стажування або якісь
інші фактори які на це можуть впливати А
якщо говорити про майстер-класи
зрозуміло це більш такий відомий формат
воркшопів тренінгів де молоді люди
можуть отримувати ці знання і навички
наприклад там з написання резюме або
підготовки до співбесіди
інтерактивний формат є флешмоби і квести
Так це більш такі розважальні Заходи які
дають можливість
певний такий потік
інтерактиву Да і при цьому можливо
отримувати щось корисне також тому часто
от заходи
профорієнтаційного формату також роблять
у форматі квестів Коли молоді люди
можуть
ознайомлюватися ознайомлюватися
наприклад із закладами освіти або там
знайомитись з якоюсь професією через
отакий проходження певного квесту
виконання міні-задань і також дні
відкритих дверей мабуть найбільш
популярний формат для закладів освіти
Коли можливо
знайомитися і розповідати більше про
навчальні програми про те які
перспективи відкриває заклад І так далі
також є цікавий формат кейс чемпіонат
або хакатон
тут іде вже зосередженість на можливість
молодої людини проявити себе проявити
себе у рішення якоїсь ситуації дуже
часто на такі як з чемпіонату запрошують
роботодавці або роботодавці пропонують
свої якісь проблемній ситуації і от
молоді люди проявляючи себе
намагаються розв'язати ту чи іншу
проблему найбільш
такі вдалі рішення оцінюється
роботодавцями І власне там отримують
нагороду або взагалі запрошується на
стажування як найбільш такі
просунуті якщо говорити Мент про
менторську програму це більше
індивідуальна робота також до це
відрізняється від формату власних
консультування Так тут уже більше йде
наставництво більше йде при форматі
консультування Ви не так багато
людині радити Так бо більше її запитуєте
і даєте їй можливості для прийняття
рішення і можливо фасилітуєте то
менторська менторство - це більше така
робота Коли ви буквально
щось можете радити людині ну з точки
зору якщо вона вам довіряє як методу так
І власне до менторства можна запрошувати
роботодавців запрошувати викладачів і
так далі дні дні ярмарки дні кар'єри і
ярмарки вакансії це власне зустрічі
знайомства роботодавців з молоддю форуми
це більш широкий формат де зустрічається
всі стикер можуть бути і роботодавці і
молодь Ми дуже
раніше багато проводили саме форуми
формати форумів де
роботодавців молодих людей і зав'язували
дискусію між ними тому що Це також
важливо для того щоб певним чином
створювати якісь нові партнерства або
Ви що що важливо для того чи іншої
аудиторії Ну і звичайно партнерські
заходи Я думаю які
індивідуально ви робите у колабораціях
так із вашими партнерами чи то
роботодавцями чи то закладами іншими
закладами освіти або громадським
сектором
щодо вони можуть стосуватися таких же
форматів які були раніше пере ні або
пропонувати якісь свої нові формати
Отож власне це такий невеличкий огляд
того що таке кар'єрний консультування
для закладів освіти воно
воно важливе в тому ключі що на кожному
етапі молода людина має відчувати що
вона
вона має певну мету так тобто коли Вона
навчається Вона має по завершенню вона
пройде до певного
професії або почне будувати свою кар'єру
тому
так так
так-так я власне завершуватиму
я власне завершуватиму тому
[музика]
для кар'єрного консультанта для
викладача або
освітянина який хоче розвиватися в цьому
напрямку важливо
розвивати власне знання теорії кар'єри
розвивати навички індивідуального
спілкування так і групового
вміти оцінювати оцінку і розуміти як
розвивається кар'єра Ну і звичайно мати
доступ до певної інформаційної бази
певних ресурсів і знань Якщо коротко То
ми як кар'єрних також маємо нашу
спільноту центрів кар'єри і закладів
вищої освіти закладів профтех освіти
Запрошуємо також до нас доєднуватися там
ми
обговорюємо даємо певний практичний
матеріал тобто те про що сьогодні
говорив розбираємо вже на такому
практичному форматі як навчитися як
кар'єрний консультант або консультантка
надавати послуги для молоді
нас є допомагаємо власне в цьому і
посилюємо трошки навички знання і Також
важливим цікавим є курс для студентів
закладів профтехосвіти які ми спільно з
міністерствами освіти презентували у
2020 році власне про які можна
користуватися також у проведенні певних
певних занять для здобувачів освіти там
власне є модуль по професійному
профорієнтації так і по підготовці до
кар'єри І власне навіть один модуль про
відкриття власної справи
ну І на завершення це те що ми вже
надаємо в нас є безкоштовні кар'єрні
консультації тому якщо у вас ваших
здобувачів також є бажання приєднатися
спільно з платформою спів діє кар'єрних
проводить безкоштовні кар'єрні
консультації тому запрошуємо вас також
або ваших здобувачів на більш такі
глибинні індивідуальні консультації
поспілкуватися про їх кар'єру
Дякуємо всім і якщо я запитання Буду
радий на них відповісти так мене Тараса
Дуже дякую вам за вашу роботу і за те що
поділилися власне форматами які Можна
реалізувати в рамках кар'єрного
консультування це вже є насправді
ґрунтовна база для нашої практичної
роботи яка нас чекає о другій половині
дня тому це дійсно корисне і не лише на
послухати а й для нашої роботи шановні
учасники тому правильно робили ще
фотографували слайди вони нам дійсно
знадобляться тож колеги чи має хтось
запитання до Тараса якщо хтось має
підніміть будь ласка руку Ліна моя
колега підійде до вас
є запитання прошу Давайте ви і потім ви
Доброго дня Я не запитання а просто
слова великої вдячності тому що ми з
паном Тарасом це грошей Олена методичний
центр Дніпро
Ми дуже вдячні вам пане Тарасові і всі
вашій команді за ту співпрацю яка у нас
з 2020 року вона є ми розпочали згоди і
далі ми по програмі skill Lab навчали
наших методистів навчально-методичного
центру після того як були вони навчені
далі йшла програма на заклади
професійно-технічної освіти тобто на
всіх хто бажав навчатися по тій програмі
і ми з минулого року запустили цю
програму і окремо працюємо вже не тільки
з
працівниками закладів
професійно-технічної освіти але із
здобувачами освіти вони склали свої
корективи війна Да ми були на форумі вас
в Одесі і після того
були в Одесі Після цього ми планували що
в Дніпрі зробимо такий же самий форум
дуже цікавий І хотіли щоб залучилося
більше молоді і знала про це все Олена
сьогоднішній день то маємо
що маємо думаємо що буде все добре І ми
все-таки в Дніпрі вас чекаємо
І ще хочу зауважити що по програмі
skelabu ми
у зв'язку з війною якби і з тим що діти
наші які без батьків ми їм окремо цю
програму проводили саме
працівників методичної служби і навчали
їх власне
кар'єрному зростанню саме саме цій
категорії дітей окремо ще дякую
Дуже дякую пані Олена Дякую за лідерство
вашого вашого управління для в цьому
напрямку тому що дійсно Бачу ви
залучалися і до програм які ми
поширювали на молодіжні центри І власне
взяли лідерство в роботі з закладами
освіти і це такий великий масштабування
наших зусиль
Людмила Шевчук Я хочу висловити теж
велику вдячність за таку представлене
системне
представлення кар'єрного консультування
хочу сказати що хмельнична теж має певні
здобутки в цьому плані у нас проходив
всеукраїнський експеримент
всеукраїнського рівня з за наказом
міністерства освіти залученням інституту
професійно-технічної освіти Тому ці
посібники і підручники посібники які
видані в межах цієї дослідної
експериментальної роботи вони очевидно і
дали підставу включити вас в перелік нас
тих областей які це ефективно
впроваджують і Це дало змогу нам на базі
ВПУ 25 в інших вищих наших навчальних
професійних закладів проводити успішне
консультування починаючи школярів
молодших молодшого шкільного віку і дало
змогу нам проводити таку провентаційну
роботу серед переселенців І провести те
що далі реально говорила багато
перепідготовки
зросло населення але в мене питання от
якщо ви вже досліджували цю проблему з
якого віку можна проводити кар'єрне
консультування оскільки
це питання ще дискутується можливо ви
дасте нам відповідь на це питання дякую
звичайно питання важливе не просто з
якого віку тому що ну мабуть біологічні
особливості менше впливають на це то
скоріше на якому етапі знаходиться
молода людина
класично починає спілкування про вибір
професії
де лише починає так говорити про
професії звичайно про професії можна
говорити з садочка так починати там
знайомитися з певними рольовими моделями
і так далі
стосовно профорієнтаційних програм уже
цілеспрямованих про усвідомлене рішення
ми говоримо з 14 Ну давайте так з 12
років ми говоримо про певний
усвідомлення своїх сильних сторін та
тобто людина вже там набуває певних
сильних сторін з нею можна дискутувати
про те до яких да тобто до яких професій
можна застосувати ці сильні сторони якщо
більш предметно то це починаючи з 14
років
коли людина вже
певним чином
підходить до такого усвідомленого
рішення да Тобто це там дев'ятий клас
10-й клас 11 або відповідно ті хто
обрали професійну освіту Та вони вже є
учнями тобто на цьому етапі
Уже йде коли приймається певне рішення
Тобто це важливо Якщо говорити про
класичний кар'єрне консультування
щодо
працевлаштування то звичайно більш
доречна про це говорити Вже на етапі 18
років коли молода людина вже більш
усвідомлено ставиться до себе як там
майбутнього працівника або працівниці
тому В нашій роботі
орієнтуючись на такий поступовий
поступовий вхід до
власне до молодої людини тобто побудову
такого знайомства з професією в нас є
методики взагалі з п'ятого класу тобто з
5-6 це певне таке знайомство взагалі з
теорією професій і так далі далі 7-8
клас це якраз 12 і 14-й 12-14 років це
вже от якраз усвідомлення своїх навичок
і далі уже безпосередньо робота з
рішенням і вибором тобто якщо ми
говоримо профорієнтацію то це десь такий
вік
Так дякую дуже Тараса за відповідь Дякую
колеги за ваші запитання Нагадую що в
кінці презентації Тараса також були
контакти тому якщо у вас будуть ще
Запитання Ви можете комунікувати
безпосередньо з нашим спікером з нашим
експертом так ну і Дякуємо організації
кар'єр Hub заплідну співпрацю яка вже
має свої результати Якими поділилися
колеги А ми рухаємося далі насправді
мені повідомили що у нас трансляція
понад 60 глядачів тож разом на цій
конференції з нами наживо та в онлайні
понад 100 людей що я вважаю чудовий
результат тож продовжуємо працювати І
зараз ми будемо говорити власне про те
як організувати роботу центрів кар'єри
розвитку кар'єри на базі закладів
професійно-професійно-технічної освіти
що для цього варто враховувати які
основні аспекти про це поговоримо з пані
Сніжаною олеу севериненко кандидаткою
економічних наук та старшої менеджеркою
розвитку трудового потенціалу USA
економічна підтримка України пані
Сніжану вам слово так презентацію бачимо
так мікрофон я вам дам Я з реквізитом
потім вам покажу його Добрий день вітаю
ще раз всіх хто тут присутній рада
бачити всі хто в онлайні рада вам
повідомити про наші здобутки дуже
коротко про проект
для того щоб вижити в цьому сьогоденні в
якому Ми зараз живемо да потрібно шукати
звісно позитив позитивом є те що з 24
лютого
2022 року проєкти лісоїдії економічна
підтримка східної України працює вже на
території всієї України і зараз
називається економічна підтримка України
тому ми вийшли за межі нашої географії і
ми готові до співпраці з усіма закладами
освіти професійної фахової передвищої
вищої освіти для того щоб через
співпрацю з вами максимально
покращити
розвиток трудового потенціалу України
через співпрацю з компаніями трошки
заплутано але
проект наш тут у трьох напрямках це
інклюзія це розвиток бізнесу і
трансформації тобто робота з громадами і
з містами для розвитку їх бачення та
стратегії та стратегії їх розвитку
безпосередньо Наша команда з розвитку
трудового потенціалу співпрацює в першу
чергу з закладами освіти для того щоб
потребам відповісти на потреби компанії
дуже перепрошую та і для закладів освіти
Ми пропонуємо
такі активності наступний слайд будь
ласка
ви бачите таку невеличку матрицю і
цей тренінги це і там грантові
активності прямі інтервенції
посилання дану презентацію вам розішлю
тому можете не робити фото все нормально
внизу посилання на реєстрацію ви зможете
прийти реєстрацію відзначити вибрати для
себе ті напрямки які вам цікаві саме
закладу у вашому закладу освіти для тієї
цільової групи Яка у вас є і
такий спосіб ми зможемо вам надсилати
вчасно інформацію про те коли ці заходи
будуть відбуватися про те як до них
долучитися для того щоб ми всі були
постійно на зв'язку значить Як ви бачите
У нас є підтримка центрів розвитку
кар'єри так викладачі в даному списку
проект працює з 2019 року Щойно він
почав розпочав свою роботу Це питання У
нас було одним із першим на яке ми
звернули увагу того часу ми зустрілися з
декількома
центрами розвитку кар'єри і в регіоні і
за його межами і зробили для себе такий
висновок
персонал центрів розвитку кар'єри у
більшості своїй є
не дуже підготовленим м'яко кажучи часто
це просто призначені люди або аспіранти
які в принципі не знають що з тим з цим
робити
і
я перепрошую Може в когось звісно
ситуація краща Це був 2019 рік але ми
вирішили звернутися
до досвіду який вже
йосеїді пропілотував у Марокко
2015-2019 роки там був окремий проект
націлений саме на створення центрів
розвитку кар'єри
такої мережі у закладах професійної
освіти вищої освіти і
продуктом даного проекту став
інструментарій для центрів розвитку
кар'єри
дістаю реквізит
Ось так Ось він виглядає
тильна сторона
в Україні єдиний екземпляр з Марокко
радо ним поділилися і чесно кажучи
перебуваючи в
офісі в Краматорську у січні місяці я
якимось дивом його звідти в останній
момент поклала в машину Ні ні ні це мій
власний будемо так казати Так
але він в мене був в офісі бо ми тоді
працювали на сході України і я його
просто забрала додому І правильно
зробила
показую далі Можна вас попросить
потримати мікрофон щоб мене було добре
чути бо мені потрібно обидві руки
так чемоданчик відкриваємо значить що у
нас тут є бачимо да
значить є
всі необхідні інструменти які потрібні
для того щоб знати як організувати
роботу центру розвитку кар'єри з чого
почати якщо ви ще не почали
що робити далі якщо ви вже почали бо ми
пам'ятаємо в Марокко даний
інструментарій даний проект вони
починали з нуля у нас ситуація інша в
нас вже є
наробки У нас вже є практики Можливо
вони десь
нестандартизовані не структуризовані
тобто і для і саме для того щоб трошки
впорядкувати
наш підхід Так ми і взяли ось цей ось
інструментарій за основу Тобто це якщо
ми говоримо про розвиток інновацій Да це
так сказати собі MVP от ви зараз бачите
прототип
з чого він складається
так як я звертаюся до спільноти закладів
освіти Ми всі любимо методички да
я одна така велика методичка такий
загальний посібник
це по крокова інструкція
дуже детальна покрокова інструкція про
те розділена на різні етапи тут в
принципі все в кольорах
початок роботи
наступний етап і розвиток
встановлення роботи і розвиток центру
розвитку кар'єри І що потрібно робити
тут детально прописано все кожен крок є
зміст
ця інформація вся детальна яка є в цьому
посібнику ось тут загальна інструкція
вона детально представлена якщо там
написано посібничок такий-то то є також
ці посібнички в окремому варіанті
інформація про них є в даному посібнику
і є ось тут
так
є часова шкала в принципі з цього треба
було почати отака бачимо початок роботи
встановлення центру і його розвиток
також вся інформація детально що на
якому етапі потрібно робити І якщо
комусь потрібно більше прочитати Що саме
робити людина прийшла не підготовлена в
центр розвитку кар'єри тоді людини є
можливість взяти ось це ось посібничок
прочитати
взяти до роботи відповідний інструмент
Чи це посібник окремий Чи це
вуаля
Ось така ось
інструкція з приводу того
Це якщо є гроші
[сміх]
да
от з приводу того як зробити такий центр
розвитку кар'єри як його оформити які
меблі підібрати Яка яке планування але
це є Ну Дивіться Ну якщо є гроші ти не
знаєш якщо їх зараз немає То не знаєш що
їх завтра не буде правильно
Може організуватися щоб податися разом
Ну от курси для того як писати грантові
заявки Ми також пропонуємо
ви бачите в списку і
так що у нас тут ще є все
є навіть постерності повісили собі вам
вже не треба нічого ніде замовляти так
як я б сказала це вже це Прототип
досвіду марок це інструментарій який був
там розроблений тут є карманчик тут ще
така флешечка де зберігається його
електронна версія я її зберігаю в іншому
місці
І що ще Ну в принципі ви бачите ще один
постер на стіну далі інші посібники
ви зрозуміли Так навіть якщо у вас у
центр розвитку кар'єри Дякую приходить
Людина яка не знає що це таке центр
розвитку кар'єру що він має робити Ви
даєте їй
кейс чемоданчик інструментарій давайте
називати його Ну кому як зручніше так і
все людина вже вона в принципі знає на
якому етапі розвитку знаходиться
центр розвитку кар'єри і будь ласка Ну
хіба що лінивий може не відкрити Да але
в Україні ось такий ось кейс да
з'явиться після того як ми
з вами його пропілотуємо зараз ми
зробили даний інструментарій ми взяли за
основу цю практику
запросили експертів які знаються на тому
що вже є в Україні зроблено і розробили
його для
закладів для центрів розвитку країни
кар'єри України
як які він має вигляд Я вам зараз покажу
хто мені допоможе переключити
презентацію
так А де той pdf файл
а там мені туди піти
Я пішла в люди давай мені потрібно
просто мати То все в руках щоб вам
показати як тим користуватися
одну секундочку
як я вам і обіцяла Ось будь ласка у вас
є той же самий таймлайн та сама часова
шкала да на екрані Я бачу що трошки
помилково на жовтому білим дуже видно
але ви бачите що покроково все прописано
в закладах професійної освіти і потім
підключилися заклади вищої так Тому від
початку Пілот планувався на три центри
але по-моєму не закінчили на стадії
але ж зважайте на те що це все
відбувалося з нуля тому ви бачили
матеріали з будівництва які потрібно
підбирати матеріали будівельні і всі
інші
раз раз Да чуть значить Дивіться і ви
переходите
це мишка
Мені потрібно мишка щоб я могла нажати
так дивіться У вас є у вас є крок у вас
є дія яку ви маєте реалізувати на цьому
кроці і У вас є посилання саме на той
документ який вам допоможе це може бути
допустим посібник із залучення молоді
що тут разрешить
і відкривається посібник із залучення
молоді він у нас тут відкрився на іншому
екрані тут зараз задача для наших
технічних спеціалістів ці всі це все
правильно
показувати так і ви маєте можливість
подивитися що це за посібники залучення
молоді що потрібно тут робити
і так далі і тому подібне якщо
повернемося можемо повернутися на
попередньо Чи це дуже складно
ні вас не звільнять
все буде нормально
я
просто розумію Дашу це і Ну давайте який
на якийсь наступний крок перейдемо
можемо
[музика]
посібники залучення молоді Ну допустимо
вас є профорієнтаційні тести у вас є
зразок презентації є
Ми навіть включили шаблони посадових
інструкцій вони якщо посібники у нас в
форматі PDF я це останній зроблю Для
прикладу добре
А я піду назад щоб вас більше не
хвилювати вони в форматі Word Тобто
взагалі скачали
підставили свої дані дані про ваш
закладу освіти і все і працюємо
для того щоб технічно зрозуміти як це
працює для того щоб пропілотувати ми
запланували офіційну презентацію даного
інструментарію на 16 листопада
2022 року
запрошуємо вас всіх інформація про даний
захід Буде реєстрація реєстрація на
нього буде оголошено на нашій сторінці у
Facebook
хто ще не знає підпишіться економічна
підтримка України
Також у нас є веб-сайт на якомусь також
є новини і там же ми вам через
демонстрацію екрану бо тут я бачу що
досить складно там хлопці є декілька
екранів і я розумію що він трошки як
фокусник зараз з ними маніпулював
я перепрошую
Значить всім зареєстрованим після
презентації ми надішлемо ось доступ до
цієї часової шкали яку я щойно показала
А можна ще раз відкрити оцю От таку
кольорову схему
доступ до часової шкали де ви матиме до
цієї Дякую де Ви матимете змогу
виходячи з того кроку на якому ви є
подивитися що ми вам пропонуємо
чи підходить це вам надіслати нам відгук
і таким чином ми будемо це все
враховувати є невеличка особливість ось
всю де матеріали є з прапорцем червоним
да це значить що це практика Марокко яку
ми не адаптували ми просто переклали
і ви можете вирішити наскільки вона є
для нас корисною або некорисною як ми
можемо її адаптувати також ми плануємо
Протягом цього року пілотування ще до
розробити компоненти Але це вже буде у
співпраці із
закладами освіти про
організацію роботи центру розвитку
кар'єри за умов війни
тому
я вас запрошу всіх на дану презентацію
16 листопада
сподіваюсь що ми з вами плідно
попрацюємо і в квітні травні Наступного
року 2023 ми вийдемо на фінальний
варіант який вже ми зможемо перетворити
Ось у таку от версію Так звісно
електронну версію також ніхто не
відміняв
перетворити в таку версію і надати
закладам освіти у користування для того
щоб вам було що вручити працівникам
центрів розвитку кар'єри щойно вони
приступають до роботи якщо ще є
запитання Я готова вам на них відповісти
будь ласка Так Олег подякуємо пані
сніжані і
і запитання
величезне Дякуємо пані Сніжано за дуже
таку цікаву презентацію насправді
хотілося мати такий інструментарій Я
думаю він нам дуже потрібен в закладах
хоча б електронну версію Я спробувала
зареєструватися зайти за формою але якщо
немає немає цього посилання електронного
Ну коли ми набираємо то не відкриваються
форма
послання на форму надано в скороченому
варіанті вам надішлю дану презентацію ви
перейдете собі за посиланням ви перейшли
те його колегам ви зареєструєтеся
залишите відгуки про те з яким напрямком
мала цікаво нам спів з нами
співпрацювати і Якщо у вас буде
відмічено напрям центру розвитку кар'єри
ми надішлемо вам запрошення на офіційну
презентацію 16 листопада Дякую тобто
електронну версію маємо має можливість
отримати інструментарію так так після
офіційної презентації де ми вам вже за
допомогою
самого екрану і способи його поширення
ми вам покажемо як то все працює віддамо
відповіді також на ваші запитання і всім
хто погодиться проходити пілотування ми
надішлемо дану часову шкалу з усіма
активними лінками де Ви матимете змогу
Перейти за посиланням ознайомитися із
текстом зі змістом посібника взяти собі
в шаблон в роботу шаблон того чи іншого
документу Ми навіть придумали тексти
оголошень про ті чи інші заходи Ну я вже
не знаю хто тоді не зможе організувати
правильно роботу центрів розвитку
кар'єри маючи маючи такі інструменти
будь ласка ще одне запитання Катерина
шикіна навчально-методичний центр
професійно-технічної освіти у Сумській
області
Я теж вам дякую я вже мала нагоду
ознайомитися попередньо з цим посібником
завдяки Вікторії Джус і Міністерство
освіти і тому в мене декілька питань
такого бо
Наскільки я зрозуміла так він
адаптований більш під Марокко
він система тому питання в мене Скажіть
будь ласка скільки професійно-технічних
закладів у них є наприклад в регіоні чи
взагалі як вона
побудована система профтехосвіти в
Марокко Давайте ми на це питання я
детальну відповідь під час офіційної
презентації бо ми запланували там
все-таки більш детально ознайомлення із
досвідом марок і там є статистика і всі
інші і результати проекту будуть і
інформація з приводу скільки вже зараз є
центрів розвитку кар'єри і він наш
інструментарій він не адаптований він
просто на основі досвіду Марокко
побудований але це не значить що ми його
просто скопіювали Ні не скопіювали ми
його повністю використали всі практики
які зараз використовується в Україні ті
практики які
ми вважаємо за доцільне Щоб
наша спільнота з ними ознайомилась вони
є в інструментарі з
прапорцем країни Марокко і вони просто
перекладені
тоді інші питання теж більше про
наприклад посібник залучення програми
молодіжних амбасадорів що для України
у нас профтехосвіті це не незвична для
нас і тому хотілось би більше про це
дізнатися тому що як воно працює взагалі
чи було це на безоплатній основі чи у
нас все це Вибачте це досвід Марокко
який ми не могли просто його ігнорувати
відкласти в сторону Ми з Ми вирішили що
нам потрібно з ними ознайомитись
вирішити що нам з ним робити дивіться не
значить що ви отримаєте цю часову шкалу
з посиланнями і ми залишаємо вас
наодинці з цим всім
протягом Наступного року ми будемо
проводити з учасниками які погодились на
пілотування тренінги
з приводу того як працювати з цим
інструментарієм як працювати з різними
цільовими групами як розвивати м'які
навички як
створювати команду
організувати роботу даного центру
розвитку кар'єри і інші Я думаю що
повний перелік нашої пропозиції щодо
тренінгів в рамках пілотування ми вам
також оголосимо 16 листопада
Дякую ми не лишаємо вас наодинці Ми не
даємо вам просто цифровий документ типу
робіть з ним що хочете і дайте нам свою
відповідь ні в якому разі ми так не
робимо Обов'язково якщо ви заявилися що
ви хочете пілотувати ви отримуєте часову
шкалу ми з вами на зв'язку Весь час до
квітня травня
2022 року ми з вами обговорюємо всі Ось
такі от моменти які можуть бути там
прийнятні нам неприйнятні вважаємо за
доцільне
скористатися практикою Марокко чи не
скористатися і в квітні травні 2023 року
ми виходимо на національний варіант
зараз вам Динамо максимально просто
версія з урахуванням усіх можливих
особливостей щоб можна мені ще я теж
представляю харківщину Наталія дяку я
дійсно мала можливість познайомитись з
тим інструментарієм тому що входила до
складу творчої групи і писали рецензію
відгук
Чесно кажучи висловлює слова подяки тому
що в цьому інструментарі якщо немає І
хто буде розпочинати як кажуть з нуля
Там дійсно є досить цікавий і матеріал
який допоможе не потрібно ніде шукати А
все в одному
там і розроблені ярмарки професії тижні
професії планування дійсно ви свою
інформацію і вже під себе підлаштовуєте
але і тренінгами з анкетуванням все по
крокові інструкції Так що я раджу Я вам
дуже вдячна за такий матеріал Він у мене
є Дякую
Так Так Так Так Так Так А тепер тихенько
поділіться з нами Давайте ми не будемо
Давайте ми не будемо зараз виходити на
той рівень Коли ми трошки порушуємо
запланований алгоритм роботи
звісно з вами колеги в яких вже є доступ
до цих матеріалів можуть поділитися але
я би просила цього не робити тому що щоб
бо у них зараз вони ті хто передивлялися
до неї інструментарій до цього моменту в
них є просто набір папок з документами Я
не знаю як вони з ним працювали
набором папок Але в тому в тому дійсно
складно було розібратися не знаючи як це
все працює вам ми запропонуємо ось такий
от вже структурований матеріал де ви
зможете без проблем переходити за
посиланнями працювати з тим що вам
пропонують і не загубитися в тому морі
документів
які насправді входять в даний
інструментарій
тому
Вам же також хочеться увійти в коло
партнерів проекту usaid економічна
підтримка України правильно
тому я вам пропоную долучатися до
пілотування даного інструментарію і
разом Нам вийти на все-таки на ту
фінальну версію яка буде наша яка буде
про нас яка буде для нас і яка
сприятиме більш структурованій
організації роботи з молоддю задля
відродження нашої країни
тож Дякуємо ще раз пані сніжані за
виступ і за відповіді
Дякую Так Дякуємо вам дуже отже маємо ще
один анонс Я б так сказав не презентація
ще анонс ще одного потужного набору
інструментів як ми вже всі побачили в
тому числі наживо так а ми колеги
рухаємося далі Ми продовжуємо нашу
розмову про те як центр кар’єри не лише
мають функціонувати а й функціонують
фактично і Зараз ми поговоримо про кращі
практики і досвід кар'єрного
консультування в рамках робочого центру
кар'єри першого центру кар'єри в Україні
які був створений на базі колківського
центру професійної освіти і запрошую для
слова для виступу Галину кучмак
так Добрий день усім Я Галина Кучми
представник Волині у нас у нас такий
існує Центр
професійної кар'єри у нас він
називається він нас вже існує більше 5
років Я зараз слухала виступи ну більш
такого теоретичного характеру про те де
можна знайти інструментарій для того щоб
працювати в цьому центрі розвитку
кар'єри професійної кар'єри у кожному
закладі є нюанси в назві цього такого
структурної такої одиниці у будь-якому
закладі професійної освіти я слухала це
все І хочу сказати тут в нас Ми з
усмішкою говорили про гроші Ось там є
багато інструментарію але гроші і там ще
такі моменти Я хочу вам зараз
представити роботу нашого центру
професійної кар'єри і поділитися всім що
у нас є У нас є забіга наперед сайт
нашого навчального закладу там є
сторінка професійної центру професійної
кар'єри і ви зможете Якщо вам
сподобається те як Я презентую і як ми
працюємо у нашому центрі ви можете
абсолютно безоплатно всім абсолютно
скористуватися і працювати так як от ми
вирішили працювати Ну чесно сказати ми
вирішили так працювати не на пустому
місці у нас були консультації з
міністерством освіти із інститутом
професійно-технічної освіти з
лабораторії професійної кар'єри цього
інституту от виступала колега із
Хмельницької області у них експеримент
такий був всеукраїнського рівня такий же
експеримент пройшли і ми так що ось
такий досвід який виник Я вважаю не на
голому місці а і у співпраці з
науковцями І власне ми Чесно кажучи
варилися в такому своєму соку тому що ми
були перші після того і після того як
вже був проведений всеукраїнський цей
експеримент почали активно ну да Навіть
Було таке зобов'язано Було створювати
Центр професійної кар'єри абсолютно всіх
закладах Отже хочеться сказати все-таки
для чого для чого той Центр професійної
кар'єри і почати з такого більш
загального особливості розвитку
сучасного суспільства Вони вимагають
необхідності трансформації вимог до
підготовки молоді у системі професійної
освіти це ми всі усвідомлюємо ми такі
люди що зібралися тут і розуміємо що це
потрібно і випускнику професійного
технічного училища закладу любого такого
його типу необхідно набути не лише
професійної компетентності йому також
потрібно визначитися з подальшою
професійною освітньою траєкторію набути
навичок працевлаштування сформувати
бажаний та досягнений образ власного
професійного майбутнього ну тощо і
однією з характеристик успішності
об'єкта професійні сфері є звичайно
професійна кар'єра
вибір напряму професійної кар'єри є
одним з важливих життєвих рішень молодої
людини тому підготовка учня птнз до
вибору та реалізації професійної кар'єри
передбачає створює певної такої системи
яка б забезпечувала супровід цього
зазначеного процесу висококваліфікований
працівник випускник
майбутній працівник випускник птнз
повинен вміти працювати в умовах
новітніх технологій постійно оновлювати
свої знання бути мобільним
конкурентноспроможний звичайно і для
того щоб певно на зайняти свою нішу на
ринку сучасного ринку праці і навчитись
планувати професійної кар'єру робота
нашого центру зацікавила науковців і
департаментом
департаментом ПТО інститутом
професійно-технічної освіти у нас на
протязі трьох років як я вже анонсувала
проходив експеримент досить
експериментальна робота і Тема нашої
експериментальної роботи була
організаційно-педагогічні умови
створення функціонування центру
професійної кар'єри учнівської молоді
власниця все проходило на базі нашого
колківського центру професійної
професійної освіти і підрозділ цього
закладу це наш є Центр професійної
кар'єри дослідження були використані для
створення методичного супроводу
функціонування центру професійної
кар'єри учнівської молоді
ось ось і знову щось не так
але не страшно так
це воно
Ага це не те
так так Ось назва нашої дослідної
експериментальної роботи і дослідження
були використані як я сказала для
методичного супроводу роботи Центру
кар'єри і наші напрацювання А це як ви
бачите ми створили пізніше Правда воно
вже трошки адаптувалось переробилося ми
створили положення про Центр професійної
кар'єри учнівської молоді
професійно-технічного навчального
закладу Також у нас є уже готові
публікації методичні рекомендації для
педагогічних працівників щодо здійснення
консультування з професійної кар'єри
існують вже і вони завантажені до нас на
сторінку звичайно ми це все не
роздрукували великими тиражами це ну
нереально було вже з таких фінансових
важливих ну питань Але воно все є його
можна знайти у нас на сайті методичні
рекомендації створення і функціонування
центру професійної кар'єри в навчальному
закладі методичні рекомендації
інформаційно-аналітичне забезпечення
діяльності центру професійної кар'єри
професійно-технічному навчальному
закладі збірник матеріалів
всеукраїнської науково-практичного
семінару який з цього приводу якраз
проходив збірник тренінгів з кар'єрного
консультування Так ми не їх не
створювались нуля ми зробили збірку
підібрали це все що необхідне по тих
етапах за якими ми працюємо і таку
збірку теж Видали і збірник
інформаційних семінарів тобто ці
матеріали ви можете з ними познайомитися
І звичайно чудовий і досвід інших країн
зокрема нам презентували досвід Марокко
Ну а тут вже ми чисто український досвід
який є адаптований тому що він проходив
з учнями нашого професійно-технічного
навчального закладу в результа взагалі
оцього експерименту ми вже після цього
чітко хоча ми цей центр ще до
експерименту власне створили але ми вже
чітко знали як працювати І тому ми
вважаємо що можна виділити Ось такі
напрямки діяльності центру
консультаційна робота з усіми
секонсультації тренінги тестування
семінари співпраця з роботодавцями тут
ми залучаємо базу вакансію презентація
роботодавці ярмарки вакансій
майстер-клас економічні екскурсії
інформаційна діяльність - це сторінка
центру як я вже про неї згадувала
професійний кар'єри на вебсаті
колківського центру професійної освіти
інформаційні буклети бюлетені фото
відеоматеріали От наприклад в нас такі
створені відеоматеріали
робітничі династії учився батько в
нашому навчальному закладі
порекомендував вчитися своєму синові і
він створили ви створили своє сто для
тірів і потім створили ми фільм і вони
розказують як можна успішно здобув
освіту просто про в тих освіті
розвиватися успішно в кар'єрному плані і
бути успішним підприємцем
значить що що ще така галузь як би чи
відділ нашої роботи це партнерство з
бізнесом владою громадським
організаціями спільні проекти обмін
досвідом навчання співробітників центру
та учнів центр
дає можливість
центр дає можливість
учням
долучитися до матеріалів не просто як це
якась окрема кімната окремо якісь
кабінет у нас це називається
інформаційний простір центру професійної
кар'єри є такий коридор величезний між
аудиторіями і ми у тому коридорі
вважаємо що це дуже достільно розмістили
всі необхідні і потрібні стенди це у нас
там є і інформатор центру професійної
кар'єри є такий стенд як успішна
виробнича практика реальна
працевлаштування ринок праці Волині що
зараз в той чи інший момент акту ально
вакансії тренінги
перелік тренінгів які ведуть проходити
як учні можуть записатися для участі у
них вони вважають що їм саме той чи інші
потрібні зараз напрямок удосконалити в
себе актуальні проекти міжнародні
проекти ярмарок кар'єри успішні
випускники основні кроки пошуку роботи
інформаційно-довід забезпечення в нас
включає і тести і довідники у світі
професії буклети інформаційні листки
базу даних підприємств організацій
фільми мультимедійні презентації і
потрібно сказати що це не просто те що
загальне ми можемо взяти ми створювали
їх самі на основі досвіду наших учнів
які побували на практиці отримали першу
робоче місце Зараз я теж більш таку
детально буду про це ще говорити а
індивідуально проконсультуватися можна в
кабінеті профконсультанта це вже окреме
таке невеличке приміщення в якому також
знаходиться наші нормативні документи
дані про наших партнерів матеріали
семінарів консультацій тренінгів
інформаційне довідкове середовище нашого
центру створено таким чином що на
перервах учні можуть переглядати відео
презентації вас проходження наприклад
практики вакансії щодо подальшого
працевлаштування цікавитися змінами
барометру професій почерпнути інформацію
про актуальні проекти ознайомитися з
планом проведення тренінг з розвиток
тренінгів з розвитком кар'єри і
компетентності записатися до участі в
них а розпочинаємо роботу ми з
ознайомчик екскурсій для учнів першого
курсу які вже прийшли до нас вчитися у
центрі професійної кар'єри
також Якщо говорити про те як ми ще
працюємо то можна сказати що кожна
молода людина яка обрала свій
професійний шлях вона потребує підтримки
щоб адаптуватися до обраної професії
розкрити свій внутрішній потенціал і
повністю самореалізуватися тому в Центр
професійної кар'єри проводяться і
семінари консультації круглі столи
конференції на які обговорюються
загальні питання пошуку роботи
планування майбутнього професійної
кар'єри можливості пошуки віддаленої
роботи що зараз дуже якраз важлива у наш
час і ми добавилися і напрямок юрис
консульт аналізує закони України про
працю інші документи які визначають
гарантії держави щодо захисту прав
громадян на працю та реалізації прав на
соціальний захист від безробіття
наприклад проводимо і ті ось тут Зразки
як семінари відбуваються консультації
зустріч з нашим юристом Ось на тренінгах
які проводяться в нашому центрі у вас
зосереджується на перевагах нових форм
самопрезентації учні вчаться поглянути
на себе так би мовити зі сторони з
якогось боку продуктивно комунікувати
Також ми їх навчаємо рекламувати себе
усвідомлювати Власне бачення реалізації
свого успіху планувати реальні кроки для
досягнення мети центр сприяє також
розвитку підприємницької ініціативи
наших учнів вони вчаться працювати в
проєктах складати бізнес-план робити
свод-аналізи абсолютно це ми проводимо
ці такі цілі конкурси де діти захищають
свої проекти тобто вони вчаться
відкривати власну справу і взагалі з
цими новими формами роботи
ознайомляться і уже Як то кажуть
виходять у світ ринку підкованими і у
цьому питанні також на Так це якраз вони
займаються спортом аналізом це все
реально те що ми проводимо ви бачите це
все Наші учні наші працівники
також центр сприяє як я сказала Тому що
підвищувалася професійна компетентність
наших учнів і на це має великий вплив
звичайно виробнича практика у центрі
нашої професійної кар'єри складено
каталоги підприємств для проходження
практики та працевлаштування учні також
мають змогу переглядати відео та обирати
місце практики на тому відео вказано
наприклад назва якоїсь організації
установи де можна пройти її адреса
можливо
можлива яка співпраця Можливо навіть для
подальшого працевлаштування яка там
заробітна плата які там вакансії ну
абсолютно буквально всі дані ми постійно
звичайно їх поновлюємо поновлюються і
кількість ще перелік тих підприємств які
в цьому плані бажають працювати з нами
зараз наступив такий час що Ми багато не
те що нам потрібно шукати цих партнерів
партнери шукають нас зараз змінився час
стосовно цього також
Центр професійної кар'єри для
закріплення розуміння престижності
обраної професії центром проводяться
такі презентації моє перше робоче місце
так Мабуть я задалеко зайшла
моя перша робоче місце і учні які
побували на практиці Вони діляться своїм
враженнями вони відповідають на
запитання тобто створюється такий або
презентація або міні відеофільм і учні
які ще не були на практиці учні молодших
класів вони знайомляться коли розповідає
такий самий там на рік старший учень для
інших учнів як йому там було Це напевно
вони йому більш повірять правда ніж
просто десь теоретично почнемо
[сміх]
так далі відповідно до міжнародних
проектів ось Якраз це вже це наш би якби
ну похвалитися коньок да І послухати по
дереву то ми відбувається зустрічі з
представниками навчальних закладів
профільних підприємств зокрема Естонії
Ми уже кілька маємо проектів з Естонії і
продовжується наша співпраця - це
золотстворською школою сільською
економіки Ось і усі проходять там
стажування на сучасній техніці все це
розширює можливості наших випускників
учні колківського центру професійної
кар'єр
хочете говорити про це правда А мені ще
час підпирає освіти є учасниками
міжнародного конкурсу з оранки
голосовський школі обслуговування і
сільської економіки республіки Естонії
проходять виробничу практику як я вже
сказала ось про перше робоче місце
стажування в те що я сказала А ось це
на підприємствах і взагалі в самому
закладі там дуже така новітня все
обладнання техніка і вони там
поліпшують свої а це Міжнародний ось цей
конкурс оранки ми займали і почесне і
сьомий перший раз приїжджали місце і
четверте а в цьому році нам дали такий
як гран-прі тобто Наші учні хоча
похвалитися новітньої технікою для
професії тракторист-машиністу ми не
сильно можемо там маємо один трактор у
ландіній теж з проекту що
так Також мабуть про себе так подумав що
не сильно а там вся техніка Передова
саме сам найсучасніша і учень приїжджає
і він повинен за один день йому
виділяють певний той трактор на якому
він проходить і має ту горанку він в
його вивчає все там що потрібно йому
знати на другий день він вже учасник
конкурсу і І переможцях ми мали В тому
році почесно четверте місце Ми були
задоволені а в цьому році просто такий
гран-прі виграли і запрошення для
більшої участі учнів у стажуванні ну це
хороший прорив для нашого навчального
закладу взагалі для всієї України такої
практикою треба ділитися Треба її шукати
таку практику тому що це дуже корисно
для учнів вся ця техніка закінчиться
війна Все буде добре все воно прийде до
нас Правда в нас будуть інвестори і учні
повинні бути обізнані із цим всім центру
також організовується економічні
екскурсії на підприємства дуже багато
хоче сказати тому що уже Ми дуже просто
багато робимо особливо їм є такий вид
екскурсії як один день на підприємстві
ось економічні екскурсії на найкраще
підприємство України
економічні екскурсії що ж вони дають
економічна екскурсія це зрозуміло там
знайомство з підприємством так чи з
організації але дуже дієвим є такий вид
екскурсій як один день на підприємстві
учні працюють на різних технологічних
процесах на новітньому обладнанні
дають різні консультації йде безперервно
така живи спілкування і після того вони
роблять звіт про той свій проведений цей
день на підприємстві звичайно
відбувається ярмарки вакансій про те що
говорилося теоретично ми все абсолютно
вже проводимо на яких виступають
роботодавці які на власному досвіді
доводять можливість побудови успішної
кар'єри і в ході живого спілкування з
роботодавцями учні випускних груп
дізнаються багато корисної інформації
про вакансії Там буквально стоять столи
сидять роботодавці підходять учні Вони
бачать нас отого підприємства до кого
хочуть сідають і просто розмовляють про
те що Їх цікавить Це наприклад дуже
корисно ніж просто в загальному говорити
коли людині приділяють увагу віч-на-віч
це і психологічно для неї підвищує її
якби самооцінку і більш дає користі під
час презентації роботодавців
представники компанії розповідають про
гарантії створення умов для
самореалізації працівників їх кар'єрного
росту про можливість забезпечення
молодих спеціалістів з житлом
харчуванням транспортом тобто все те що
важливо для молодої людини потім
приїжджав до нас один випускник каже та
я пропрацював я у Львові працюю на
підприємстві мені там дали квартиру Я
кілька років Добре пропрацював мені
виділили автомобіль Я ніколи не думав що
це мене так буде швидко все в житті і це
воно відбулося знаєте який це Стимул для
тих хто навчається і шукає майбутнє
місце роботи учням цікаво звичайно
знайомитися із підприємствами адже вони
можуть стати реальним місцем для
проходження виробничої практики та
працевлаштування Також ми постійно
проводимо заходи із Волинським обласним
центром зайнятості
підсумувати Чим вам підсумувати Давайте
я вам ще покажу що ми презентації
роботодавців ці що ми проводимо так
чи вже зупинимо можливо час ні та
Волинський центр зайнятості Ми там
абсолютно різні проекти ярмарки професії
вони До нас приїжджають вони міняють
барометр професії абсолютно все у нас
іде у співпраці із цим
і з цим це інші філіал просто центру
зайнятості обмін досвідом Я хочу сказати
що у нас були вже до війни в нас були
представники і Запорізької області і
Хмельницької області і Рівненської
області Дніпропетровської області вони
переймали наш досвід вони вже були
готові до створення цих центрів
професійної кар'єри і Власне вони теж
створили їх і були задоволені тим що
вони побачили у нашому центрі
обмін досвідом це ми в Хмельницьку ви
бачили певно представник фестивалі різні
конкурси це теж дуже піднімає самооцінку
і мотивацію до кар'єрного росту учнів
майбутніх працівників які на
майстер-класі оце я хочу ще одне слово
скажу вона ми проводимо було запитання з
якого часу вже доцільно ну взагалі
говорити про кар'єру про професію ви
знаєте Ми запрошуємо і в нас черга Ми
запрошуємо представників шкіл молодших
класів починаючи там з другого класу ми
бачите пошили їм такі гарну форму а
раньшевого кольору ми ви їх називаємо
Курчатка оті Курчатка приходять вони
самі ліплять ті коржечки вони самі їх
оздоблюють чай все з цими коржечками ви
знаєте ті Курчатка вже деякі виросли в
дорослих наших абітурієнтів і вони
кажуть що вони з того часу як вони
приходили в другому класі до нас Вони
вже в них десь там в голові відклалося
що я хочу тут вчитися Розумієте це такий
емоційний такий мотив і емоційний стиль
ви всі знаєте психологічно Він дуже
впливає на на рішення на обрання рішення
навчатися в тому чи іншому навчальному
закладі
Отже я хочу сказати Ну майстер-класи
вони там і їздять на чомусь на всяких
транспортах Бачите я вже так сумбурно
говорю бо мені ж не дали Вже часу а я ще
хочу говорити
Ну вже не хоче навіть перекрити
переключатися ярмарки давайте О а
дивіться так А оце наше епогей це свято
професії там дуже учнів багато завжди
всі окремо форму бачите Який в нас зал
Скільки в нас учнів нас більше 600 учнів
навчається Отже я хочу вам сказати ми
працюємо ми вже давно створили цей центр
Ми пройшли всеукраїнський експеримент Я
запрошую вас до нас приїжджайте ми вам
все покажемо розкажемо як воно
відбувається насправді або Заходьте хто
не має можливості на
нашу сторінку у нас колківський Центр
професійної освіти А там є сторінка
Центр професійної кар'єри і там
абсолютно всі матеріали про все і як
зробити що робити якщо вас щось
зацікавить я буду вдячна що мій наш
досвід допоміг вам у створенні і роботі
і звичайно я надіюсь що і вже почула
багато і ще почую на сьогоднішній нашій
зустрічі щоб покращити роботу цих
центрів Майте Я впевнена і запевняю вас
що вони потрібні ці центри Вони працюють
і вони дуже допомагають нашим учням
стати більш розвинутими в нашому
сучасному світі дякую за увагу
на основі
одного
даний вона не є пенальним ваша роль Як
е-е тих профілатує також може бути в
тому що ви можете
запропонувати своїй практиці і в такий
спосіб у вас не буде обмежений сказали
що вас не було коштів для того щоб
опублікувати
теж Дякуємо так
Дякуємо дуже за виступ експертів на
цьому цей блок колеги ми завершуємо і
перерви на таких заходах які
відбуваються наживо це не лише така
можливість перезарядити свою внутрішні
батарейки цей можливість поспілкуватися
з нашими експертами познайомитись один з
одним до чого я вас закликаю Власне під
час перерви яка я буде зараз але саме ця
перерва має ще пару важливих
організаційних моментів тому прошу вашу
хвилинку уваги А хто сьогодні виїжджає
адміністрація готелю просить дати
ключики від номерів так от буквально Під
час цієї перерви прошу вас це зробити
для тих хто хоче трошки підживитися
кавою печіком то біля зовні нашої
конференціалу доступний кавабрейк так і
сюди давайте повернемося з 10 хвилин
тобто о 12:05 знаю що в нас уже є
спікери на зв'язку в онлайні колегію
Вітаю вас о 12:05 будемо розпочинати
панельну нашу дискусію колеги Дякую вам
зараз невеличка перерва в тому
і о 12,5 знову у цій залі продовжуємо
нашу розмову
ми тебе бачимо
добре
Всім доброго дня давайте протестуємо
поки в нас є декілька хвилиночок
звуки відео ми Зараз перевіримо
Оля пушина все бачимо чуємо пані Олеся
Кравченко
Скажіть будь ласка що-небудь щоб ми
почули що є звук а все чудово Дякуємо
пані Людмила Доброго дня
Ага все гаразд
Так тут ми бачимо
так ну ніби все гаразд супер Ми зараз
Запрошуємо учасників і будемо вас теж
підключати і виводити на екран дякуємо
дріжців
і просто ваш автор в мережу кидає адрес
ви знаєте
ви не знаєте
Мені зараз треба згадувати зараз через
три хвилини перейде вона знов щоб я щось
її воду внизу Я не маю коли в принципі
нормально включилися в синіх гніздо
бо то не є туда йде туди інтернет воно
йде на пульт на звук
Ну він тільки роздає звук внутрішню все
болів по комп'ютерних
через те що ми підключалися просто ваш
роутер видає в систему адрес і він
просто закриває всі останній
доступні Зараз я включу
повертатися вже продовжувати працювати
розпочинати вже дуже-дуже скоро панелі
дискусії тому запрошую вас до залишок
але мені спікери Дякую що ви з нами
роз'язочку вже трошки з вами
налаштувалися а
забрекуємося коли вже долучиться всі
наші спікери хто наживо хто в онлайні
ось приклад у нас буде простий питання
всім розсилали Тому все буде класно
цікаво інтерактивно
раз два три
так колеги запрошую вас повертатися
сподіваюсь кава Брейк був смачним але це
лише кавабрейк попереду обід А щоб
встигнути на обід Треба встигнути з
нашої панельною дискусії
три хвилиночки Окей А давай тоді
31.1
Дякую тим хто вже повернувся панове
спікера чи чуєте ви мене
дайте знати що ви мене чуєте
чудово Я вас теж чую все чудово А ось
дивіться давайте трошки забрекуємося Хто
зі мною спікер наживо прошу за цей
столик
і так що добре у нас загалом буде
розглядатися три запитання які ми
заздалегідь розсилали в джензі вони і
учасників такі самі А вони не будуть
сюрпризом насправді але три надзвичайно
актуальні запитання і для відповіді на
Кожне з цих запитань кожен із вас кожен
із спікерів буде мати до 3 хвилин нас
які є багато тому я дуже попрошу вас
слідкувати персонально за таймінгом щоб
не довелося зупиняти перебивати Так я
певен що зможемо впораємося Коротко і по
суті так скажемо покрити ці запитання
ось тож кожному із вас на кожне
запитання буде відведено три хвилини я
Роман керівник центру кар'єри книге
імені Тараса Шевченка мадератор
сьогоднішнього заходу і зокрема дискусії
і буду трошки можливо змінювати порядок
виступу спікерів щоб не був хтось завжди
останній чи завжди перший Чи все було
справедливо Ось такі формати і при
відповіді на перше запитання звісно я на
початку всіх вас представлю так привіт
на перше запитання ви будете мати
додаткову одну хвилинку представити себе
установою яку ви презентуєте така-то
жовтня Окей доступна
по брифів в мене все можливо ви маєте
запитання
колеги хто з онлайн Окей чудово
Так зараз тоді Зачекаємо на всіх наших
учасників фоточки тут тоже треба тому
Зачекаємо
бачимо вже наших спікерів хто наживо
Дякую всім тим хто знайшов можливість
долучитися в онлайні знову ж таки
враховуючи наші реалії зі зв'язком з
інтернетом ніщо не зламає нашу волю
продовжувати свою ефективну роботу
навчання наших учнів і власне наш
сьогоднішній зак- захід який
відбувається от Саме тут є тому
підтвердження
Так я думаю
потрошку можемо починати можемо починати
мені кажуть а-а але друзі перед тим як
розпочати безпосередньо саму дискусію
важливий аспект власне проекту і фоскілс
так і конкретно цього закладу в тому
числі це те що цей великий проект так
він Ця програма підтримки кар'єрного
консультування закладом професійного
професійно-технічної освіти цей проект
реалізується спільно з Європейським
Союзом його країнами-членами такими як
Німеччина Франція іншими країнами за
підтримки організації Гіс за підтримки
федерації роботодавців України досвіти і
науки України але той контент який
оголошується публікується в рамках
проекту Він не є не може бути сприйнятий
як думка Євросоюзу чи саме організації
партнерів він є відповідальністю
спікерів тих хто його репрезентує ось
тому зважте на це це такий теж важливий
момент який варто врахувати і до так
скажемо
міні-вітального слова перед початком
нашої дискусії Я хотів би запросити пані
Ольгу пушину яка з нами в онлайні вона є
регіональною координаторкою проекту і
фоскілс в Запорізькій області тож Ольго
вам слово для вітання наших учасників
Дякую Романе Вітаю усіх шановних
учасників шановний призидом усіх вітаю
Сподіваюся ви мене чуєте та бачите
щиро дякую всім хто долучився до нашого
заходу щиро дякую слухачам учасникам і
Міністерство за підтримку у за сприяння
в організації таких заходів особливо
наживо це дуже важлива наразі
щиро дякую нашим партнерам іншим донорам
спікером за те що ми знаходимося енергії
за те що ми робимо усе що покращити
навички знання наших освітян Ну і Дуже
щиро дякую освітянам за те що ви берете
участь у наших заходах у наших тренінгах
Ви дуже активні ви великі молодці і я
сподіваюсь що
нашими спільними зусиллями ми робимо
велике внесок в нашого спільного
перемогу
Також я вірю що такий Захід Як
конференція сьогодні яка і наступні
конференції це такий важливий внесок не
лише в розбудову потенціалу кадрового
потенціалу потенціалу України а також і
в те що кожна особистість може
побудувати свою оптимальне професійну
траєкторію і я вважаю всім плідності
праці сьогодні щоб ви не лише
попрацювали
активно А ще відпочили ще й
поспілкувалися отримали те натхнення і
мотивацію для подальшої роботи і
і відпочили Отже щиро Всім дякую і до
нових зустрічей Я сподіваюсь що
наступного разу і я буду з вами назва і
в нас ще багато попереду Дякую Так дякую
дуже вам Ольга дійсно багато попереду і
багато сьогодні попереду власне і ми
будемо розпочинати нашу панельну
дискусію Отже Тема нашої панельної
дискусії - це є кар'єрний консультування
учнів закладів професійної та
професійно-технічної освіти Так це є
виклики сьогодення і наші плани цілі на
майбутнє те що ми будемо говорити в
рамках найближчої півтори години і з
нами сьогодні на зв'язку наживо та в
онлайні будуть такі експерти Леся
Кравченко директорка Департаменту
молодіжної політики Міністерства молоді
та спорту Лесі вітаємо
Доброго дня Добрий день радіо чутися
Людмила василега директор центру
компетенції та розвитку людського
капіталу федерації роботодавців України
Добрий день Доброго дня З вами почутися
Анастасія голотенко координаторка
напрямку кар'єрного консультування
кар'єр-хаб го центр розвитку
корпоративного соціальної
відповідальності
Анастасія
Анастасія чуєте нас
е-е Окей можливо Анастасія долучиться
підключитися згодом Марина Джулай
керівниця HR бренд агенції Юджин в
Україні
Доброго дня Добрий день Радий чутися
також з нами Рибак Наталія викладач і
член робочої групи з центру кар'єри ДП
тнз вінницьке професійне училище сфери
послуг так вітаємо наживо і також з нами
з цього ж закладу учень Олександр
бойленко Олександр вітає нас вітає
навіть наживо так радий чутися знову ж
таки з дуже різними представниками
стеколдерами як там ми називаємо саме
освітнього процесу ось з нами також на
зв'язку вище професійне училище номер 22
міста
Сарни яке презентую представляю сьогодні
Лариса шатирко заступник директора з
навчально-виховної роботи чуєте нас
вітаємо і також з цього закладу з нами
Яна Дударик майстер виробничого навчання
Доброго дня колеги дуже радий почутися
чи долучилися до нас Анастасія з
кар'єр-хаб Окей Поки що немає можливості
Анастасії долучитися ми будемо
розпочинати і підключимо по можливості
по наявності світло ми маємо враховувати
наші реалії такі як вони є і Отже
розпочинаємо нашу дискусію перше
запитання звучить Таким чином які
існують слабкі місця у кар'єрному
консультуванні учнів і що ми маємо
зробити вже зараз для створення
ефективних центрів кар'єри я тут додам
трошки контексту ми от уже О дякую за те
що ви ввели зону ради бачити всіх
спікерів перед собою так Сказати Так от
до запитання повертаючись ми вже маємо
приклади в центрі кар'єри які працюють
ми маємо центри кар'єри які лише
створюються так і от ну якими є Оці
критерії ефективності що варто зробити
можливо для старту для того щоб оці наші
формати кано-консультування були дійсно
ефективними дійсно так мали вплив на
учнів позитивний вплив ось про це зараз
Поговори говоримо Ну і просто такі місця
звісно те що ми їх могли їх виділити
змодерувати і щоб числа такими місця
перетворилися на сильні сторони і першою
до відповіді на це запитання дискусії
запрошую пані Лесю Кравченко з
міністерством молоді та спорту Лесі Яка
ваша думка з приводу першого запитання
через цей випадок адвокатуємо питання
молоді
для нас важливо в першу чергу аспект
злучення так мотивація саме молодих
людей а Оскільки ми знаємо що наші
молоді люди достатньо специфічно
відносяться до різних структур які
створюються державними інституціями тут
моя хочу поговорити в першу чергу про
підвищення рівня довіри да молоді до
таких інституцій Ну і відповідно якщо
буде Довіра то буде
більше попит і буде більше молодих людей
цікавитися такими от центрами кар'єра
тому що не дивлячись на те що є великі
попит самих молодих людей в таких
послугах
і ми і це доказували різні опитування
так все одно ми стикаємося з тим що в
більшості випадків молоді люди хаотично
а-а
посипають інформацію яка стосується
їхнього кар'єрного розвитку чи вибору
професії
скоріше з альтернативних джерел не в
першу чергу стосуються більш якихось там
іноземних так
методики чи
цікавляться як
роботодавці Працюють як працевлаштовують
які можливості мають е-е на ринку праці
за кордоном Ось і тому я вважаю що якраз
от така
питання залучення молоді в першу чергу
це треба підсилювати і зрозуміти як
краще це робити і друге - це все ж таки
партнерство тому що ми представники
державних інституцій е-е більшості
випадків сильні якраз в тому що ми у
співпраці з нашими партнерами робимо
спільно да щось для нашої молоді і з
такими організаціями наприклад центр
розвитку особливими системи
відповідальності Як сьогодні зазначав
Тарас і проти ініціативи і тому якраз от
в цьому партнерстві посиленні
партнерства між громадським сектором та
е-е сектором роботодавців буде наш успіх
Дякую Так дякую дуже за вашу лаконічну
відповідь фахову відповідь Ми
продовжуємо наші обговорення До речі
колеги якщо в когось будуть запитання із
залу ви їх Ну теж скажіть якщо по
тематиці Будемо якось адаптувати наші
запитання А зараз я передаю слово пані
Людмилі василезі з Федерації
роботодавців України і знову ж таки
говоримо Ми про питання того які є
слабкі сторони так і що ми маємо зробити
От вже зараз перші наші кроки для того
щоб центри кар'єри закладів
професійно-технічної професійної освіти
були ефективними тож Людмила вам слово
дякую за запитання Дякую за запрошення
Ще раз вітаю всіх учасників які і онлайн
і які присутні на під час конференції Я
представляю це роботодавця зокрема центр
компетенції та розвитку людського
капіталу але як представник сам
інституції Федерації працюють з лютого
до цього працювала на підприємствах
металургії та українська залізниця і
тому дуже дотична до питань дуальної
освіти до питань кар'єрного
консультування до роботи з молоддю і як
роботодавець безпосередньо яким проводив
такі зустрічі з молоді щодо центри
кар'єри на мій погляд Як практика яка
безпосередньо займалася з різними
закладом освіти різного рівня
центр кар'єри які слабкі міста якщо їх
виділяти ви знаєте
єра Ми кажемо про кар'єрника
консультування що таке кар'єра Да що
таке взагалі слово кар'єра як іноді
кажуть юристи подивись походження слова
да це якийсь певний рух вперед з якоюсь
метою Ну так як кажуть хлопці наша там
певного довідники тощо якщо кар'єру
центр існують здорових освіти То
наскільки вони системні наскільки вони
поєднують з цим кар'єрний шлях на
протязі різних років навчання в різних
інституціях наскільки це єдина система
на мір погляд до цього треба придивитися
тому що єдина система все ж таки повинна
існувати щоб не було різних підходів і
певно різноманіття за рахунок залучення
до цієї справи різних стихолдеров другий
як я казала раніше певна слабке місце на
мій погляд саме птах мета існування
центрів кар'єри тому що
чому зараз є великі дискусії між
роботодавцями та закладами освіти дуже
багато роботодавців на задоволені якістю
підготовки тому що є невідповідний
змістом результатів навчання вимогам
робочого місця і відповідність кількості
або самих професійних кваліфікацій
спеціальності вимогам робочого місця
тобто
застаріла інформація про потреби це
місце про стан розвитку галузі і на мій
погляд певна така інерції
освітніх процесів які зараз існують і
кого готують безпосередньо для робочого
місця для ринку праці тому Яка мета і
напевно результат існування центру
кар'єри ми побачимо тоді ефективність
Якщо ми будемо бачити що наш ринок праці
Ну майже ну не буває там 100%. я це
розумію але майже задоволений тим кого
готує як готуємо і з яким набором знань
він та навичок компетентності виходить
фахівці на ринок праці і наскільки в них
це є певне бажання тому що кар'єри
кантелювання - це частина професійної
орієнтації і Нам необхідно бачити як ми
профорієнтуємо не просто йде
профорієнтація за рахунок тільки тестів
А ми регулюємо це питання і спрямовуємо
нашу молодь на те що більш затребувано і
те що розвивається саме в нашій країні в
нашій економіці Тому що тут дуже важливо
і
тоді на мій погляд і якщо буде
відповідність Коли у нас будуть такі KPI
знаєте як бізнес які пі-i які індикатори
ефективності коли ми будемо бачити що
дійсно це спрацьовує тому наша система
буде ефективною ці три кар'єру будуть
дійсно відповідати своєму змісту ну ці
це на мій погляд Так дякую дуже Я
повністю погоджуюся з вашою думкою що це
є комплекс заходів це дуже багато
пов'язаних знову ж таки учасників цього
процесу і коли ми працюємо спільно
злагоджено власне на тему працюємо і
сьогодні в рамках казали вам програму
UFO Skills то тоді це буде ефективний
центр кар'єри І власне його заходи
формату рухаємося далі колеги і зараз
хотів би надати слово Олександру власне
учню так тобто представнику для якого ми
з вами працюємо ну і тут я мабуть уточню
контекст які формати саме вам Олександре
хотілось би отримати від вашого центру
кар'єру щоб ви зрозуміли оце для мене
цінно це мені допоможе знайти роботу
один
колеги я що хочу сказати ми з вами
трішки по різні сторони Справа в тому що
я знаю учнів не лише на уроках Я з нею
На перервах під час дозвілля я з нею
переписках де немає вчителів
що хочу сказати стосовно слабкі місця у
кар'єрному консультуванні з того що я
помітив саме не під час уроків нам учням
здається що ми і так вже все знаємо
що нас вже можна навчити ми життя бачили
Ми молоді і світ іде вперед Ми все
знаємо
Що з цим робити Особисто я в межах
нашого навчального закладу нагадаю це
Вінницьке вище професійне училище сфери
послуг сам я навчаюсь на кухара
Сократ мені дуже допомагає сократичний
діалог
справа така діалог Платона держава
Сократ веде розмову Ми щойно
спілкувались як юристів визначення
поняття Сократ запитує в хлопців Що таке
справедливість йому кажуть
справедливість це коли людина дала тобі
меч а ти тій же людині також віддасиш
Сократ каже добре а якщо ця людина
зійшла з розуму ти її віддаєш меч вона
вбиває себе та свою сім'ю вони йдуть
далі у спілкуванні секрету кажуть добре
справедлива людина це та людина якій
можна просто довірити тримати речі вона
не знає хто їх має забрати хто їх йому
приносить секрет продовжує далі а
щоб вона їх оберігала ці речі вона ж
повинна протидіяти їхній крадіжці тобто
знати яких вкрадуть йому кажуть так
секрет продовжує От бачите ваша
справедлива людина - це людина яка знає
якраз речі
Що з цим робити Я б сказав вирішення
проблеми - це є обережне повернення у
реальність діти не зовсім відображають
дійсний Навколишній матеріальний світ з
того що я бачу Можливо на уроках інша
картина Але у наших переписках у нашому
дозвіллі все абсолютно по-іншому і скажу
вам ще таки один момент він неприємний
але дуже важко як я бачу сприймаються
викладачі
більш похилого віку здається що часто
кажуть чи радянське виховання і таке
подібне я пояснюю що це не так але на
жаль є такий стереотип Перепрошую що
було так до мене запитання які формати
хотілось би отримати від центру кар'єри
щоб ти щоб ви зрозуміли що оце корисно
це допоможе знайти роботу
які поради
найперше - це пошук роботодавця і як з
ними спілкуватись ще цікавий момент ось
в нас було посібник із залучення молоді
Я так розумію ми його отримаємо так на
пошту Так це в рамках проекту також буде
розповсюджено Я просто думаю що найкраще
що може бути це колегіальна робота самих
учнів ніби як невеличкі гуртки між собою
коли однодумці про це спілкуються і тут
вже консультант кар'єрний він вже буде
не як наставник роби так роби Ось так а
це буде ніби Як ментор який направляє і
надає лише підказки рушійні сили лише її
направляє
Так дякую дуже Олександр за вашу думку
доволі Цікаво було послухати от саме
пряму живу мову це дуже цінно саме для
загалом так і для наших форматів в тому
числі а зараз запрошую до слова пані
Марину джолай з hrbit агенції Юджин Яка
ваша думка який є слабкі місця
кар'єрного консультування І от що
центром кар'єри перш за все робити ваше
слово
дякую я вже комунікую з університетами
закладами професійної технічної
підготовки фахівців вже 4 роки в рамках
Юджин і свого досвіду можу сказати що
найбільша проблема якщо можна сказати
або слабке місце Як ви сказали романи це
комунікація на рівні з учнями тому що
дуже часто керівниками цих центрів
кар'єри є викладачі є Які паралельний в
центрі кар'єри і викладають які не
завжди слідкують за трендами що зараз
цікаво для молоді як вони спілкуються по
лексико вони використовують навіть Ті
самі сленгові слова зараз вони постійно
оновлюються змінюють плюс формат подачі
як на комунікуємо це теж важливо чи ми
використовуємо багато тексту що ми це
все оформлюємо коротке відео на 15
секунд це теж має велике значення Зараз
для учнів з якими ми проводимо кар'єрний
консультування Як довго ми ведемо цю
комунікацію якщо ми це в офлайні чи в
онлайні зустрічаємося це теж впливає на
відчуття учнями так як зараз всі хочуть
якомога коротше термін отримати максимум
саме молодого покоління скажемо так і в
принципі загалом всі зараз намагаються
управляти своїм часом і отримувати
максимум ефекту Тому це теж впливає як
довго проводити ці кар'єрні консультації
як як не подаємо на якій мові Ми
спілкуємося з ними і як ми позиціонуємо
цей центр кар'єри для наших учнів тобто
хто ми є для ними ми є для ними ще одні
структурою яку просто потрібно знати до
якої потрібно дослухатися тому що це
сказали керівництво ті їх куратор чи їх
керівник наприклад декан так як вони нас
сприймають як ми себе позиціонуємо чи ми
позиціонуємо навпаки як наставники ті
хто допоможуть їм професійно зростати ті
хто допоможе їм знайти саме тих чесних
роботодавців які будуть їх розвивати а
не використовувати їх чи моя
позиціонуємо себе як нездам якесь
крутого плавання чи вони можуть прийти з
будь-яких запитань поставити будь-які
запитання щодо кар'єри і ми їм
допоможемо тобто тут ще потрібно
проаналізувати як вони позиціонуємо себе
в рамках нашого навчального закладу
серед цих учнів тому найбільша така
слабке місце загалом для мене як я бачу
це є комунікація і вона проявляється в
тому як ми говоримо як ми подаємо
інформацію Як довго ми проводимо
перевірні консультації і як ми себе
позиціонуємо для учнів навчального
закладів Так дякую дуже Марино за вашу
думку почули про нову аспект власне
комунікативний Це звісно дуже вагомий
аспект адже ми всі перш за все один
одному люди так тобто ці істоти люди які
між собою комунікують спілкуються
взаємодіяти тому звісно навіть в аспекті
кар'єрного консультування комунікації є
дуже важливою рухаємося далі нагадаю про
наше запитання Тобто це є слабкі місця в
кар'єрному консультуванні які можуть
існувати і
формат для центру кар'єри на старті що
робити вже зараз так для ефективної
співпраці з нашими учнями слово надаю
пані Наталії Рибак викладач викладачу
училище сфери послуг
що мотивація одна слабких місць тому що
Наші учні які приходять до навчального
закладу вони відповідно не вмотивовані
багато хто взагалі не знає чого потрапив
да тобто вони не визначені в своїй
професії Багато кого привели батьки і в
цьому плані є велика проблема тобто я
думаю що центр
кар'єрного консультування має з цим
працювати також
вже в ході дискусії виникло така думка
про те що потрібно популяризувати сам
центр да щоб Учні не шукали інформацію
де інде А щоб вони знали чітко куди вони
можуть звернутися
наступний етап це залучення фахових
спеціалістів Після виступу Олександра
Блейка який є учнем ви розумієте якого
рівня мають бути педагоги які мають йому
досить корисний дати далі відсутність
чітких планів і програм тобто але я так
розумію що ми сьогодні зібралися і
активно з цим працюємо тому що є певний
інструментарій який був представлений на
сьогоднішній нашій зустрічі ну і ще є
така проблема да це відсутність
стабільного фінансування Я думаю що ми
про це не говоримо але якщо люди які
працюють в принципі в цьому центрі вони
є вмотивовані є якісь певні фінансові
видатки щоб це все Ну в цьому плані
працювати то це зовсім інша історія І
зовсім інший зовсім інша ефективність
роботи Дякую Так дякую дуже за думку і
продовжимо саме чути думки можливо кейси
реалізовані так від викладачів від
безпосередньо закладів
професійно-технічної професі освіти і
запрошую до слова пані Ларису та пані
Яну з вищого професійного училища номер
колеги
доброго
днями
в помірному консультуванні є зазвичай те
що студенти так якби не усвідомлюють і
їхній вибір
цього так якби не впевнений Вони
вибирають свої професії але не розуміють
які саме є їхні кар'єрний ріст
і вони не розуміють куди їм рухатись і в
якому напрямку
ви нас чуєте все чудово
А ви нас чуєте
пані Лариса пані Янович так чуємо колеги
Можливо коли Трошки
мабуть перепідключимося але будемо
продовжувати нашу дискусію колеги Якщо
ви нас чуєте залишаємося на зв'язку ми
вас чудово чуємо Якщо ви нас чуєте то
все окей Ми продовжимо спілкуватися
а ви нас
Ми чуємо
Окей Ну давайте поки ми Очікуємо на
вирішення цих технічних моментів у колег
трошки підсумуємо про що ми вже
поговорили саме в рамках питання про те
які є слабкі сторони так і що робити вже
зараз для ефективних центрів кар'єри
перше - це робота з мотивацією мотивація
учнів на етапі вступу мотивація учнів
безпосередньо коли вона навчаються Це в
тому числі робота з випускниками так
другий - це формат комунікації які ми
реалізуємо і Отут я додам можливо
аспекту свого центру кар'єри Так нехай
університетську але в принципі
співпрацюємо з молоддю так і особливість
в тому що ми маємо йти в ті канали де
перебувають Наші учні де вони
спілкуються то можливо чати в соцмережах
месенджерах і так далі Тобто ми маємо
Чима інструментами володіти де ефективно
комунікацією колеги ті чуєте нас зараз
ларисою Яну
так тоді продовжимо Наступне Що я хотів
би відзначити
все чудово А ви нас
Отже наступний формат - це так все
чудово колеги ми вас чуємо з самого
початку
не розуміють свою обрану професію саме
На яку професію вони прийшли що що від
них вимагає тобто прийшли тобі навчатися
і прийшли
і Я рахую що ефективним
ефективністю в центрі кар'єрі повинно
бути обов'язково мотивація дітей для
того аби вони мали можливість навчатися
по обраній професії і розуміли що саме в
цій професії є їхній кар'єрний ріст він
є обов'язкового Я наприклад як майстер
виробничого навчання Коли діти приходять
на навчання я в першу чергу буквально
через тиждень відразу на виробничому їй
поколі їм показую сторінки наших
випускників перукарів тому що Я навчаю
перукарів і це Я рахую є дуже великою
мотивації для ринку що вони розуміють що
після закінчення нашого навчального
закладу діти здобувають дуже Хорошого
кар'єрного зросту І таким способом я їх
цього і відразу даю підписку сторінках
Instagram де вони бачать
розвиваються діти після нашого
навчального закладу і що ця професія от
перукар перукар але можна досягти дуже
великих успіхів
Дякую Дуже за вашу думку
Дякую Дуже за вашу думку так Ну І от
бачимо ще одне підтвердження
безпосередньо від ще одного закладу який
активно розвиває формати кар'єрного
консультування в тому числі для учнів що
мотивація є дуже важливою іноді навіть
визначально в аспекті в тому числі
такого от роботи з учнями що хотів би ще
додати знову ж таки це є формування
запиту до роботодавця про це наші колеги
теж трошки згадували тому що одне діло
коли роботодавець до нас приходить за
якимось пропозиціями працевлаштування
стажування може бути так проходження
практики але інший аспект коли ми як
центр кар'єри самий йдемо до
роботодавців Яким є в нашому регіоні І
кажемо в нас як кваліфіковані фахові
учні випускники так і скажіть прийдіть
до нас Розкажіть що ви для них можете
запропонувати Так це теж є важливий
аспект який в тому числі На мою думку
має реалізовувати центр ну і звісно те
про що казала пані Людмила це є
комплексний підхід до всієї цієї справи
тому що коли воно один від одного
ефективність точно буде страждати тому
що це підхід системний Наші учні мають
знати що центр кар'єри діє завжди в тому
числі там Можливо на канікулах от інша
справа коли вона до нього приходять
звертаються читають якісь анонси але
центр кар'єри має працювати система це
теж дійсно важливо
так переходимо до другого запитання мені
кажуть що в нас також має змогу вже
підключитися Анастасія з кар'єрхаб
чудово а друге запитання нашої дискусії
звучить Ось таким чином як іволюціонують
пріоритети молоді щодо їх Запитів до
роботодавців І що може змінитися в
найближчому майбутньому ну тут Що варто
зазначити ми можемо бачити там щорічну
статистику по тому які є
професії Які спеціальності є найбільш
затребуваними серед абітурієнтів
вступників так ось наприклад ті ж
кухар-кондитер слюсар перукар Кравець
так ті що ну мають великі запит на які
вступають наші здобувачі Так але ж іще
інше аспект - це їх запит так Тобто це
їх певна можливо Відчуття залученості і
так далі не буду тут забирати так
скажемо слово наших експертів які з нами
на зв'язку і давайте відповіді на це
запитання
розпочнемо з пані Людмили з Федерації
роботодавців України
Так дякую колеги щодо запиту до
роботодавця так питання звучить І у мене
Потім до речі там буде невеличка
декілька слайдів щодо Запитів від
роботодавців ну скажете коли краще їх
буде показати яка зараз пізніше так
Дякую Ну я б хотіла щоб перед тим як
запит до роботодавчої молоді хотіла
трішки знаєте внести таку Ну не
провокацію а провокативним зауваження
зробити тому що на мій погляд Ми більше
кажемо зараз про процес не Про результат
ну нас багато звучить цей Сьогодні речі
їм про процес ми робимо мотивацію це
важливо мала чую про результати що є
результатом роботи кар'єрного Центру що
є результатом дійсно
правильно або ефективного консультування
тому колеги більше треба нам якщо ми
проводимо зараз зустрічі І ми за
результат зустрічі потім хочемо поєднати
зусилля давайте разом працювати
результат що буде результату це не
просто знати Навіщо я прийшов професію
це потім розуміти де ти хочеш працювати
і кар'єрний розвиток це само про це каже
що людина розуміє де потім буде
працювати І якщо ми кажемо про мотивацію
це до речі тотожні Визначення що кар'єра
- це рух чи мотивація знаєте іноді
роботи відрізняє мотивацію від
матеріального стимулювання коли працюють
з людьми у бізнесі то мотивація це як
можна сказати так трошки з гумором що
коли ти робиш щось з посмішкою на
обличчі і без грошей Чому ти встаєш щоб
це робиш Чому це ти робиш Чому це все
зробив тобі ніхто за це не платить Але
ти робиш Це мотивація це певний рух
вперед тобто побуждение як то кажуть
людина і тому мотивація у нас треба
звернути увагу на професійну орієнтацію
на цінності на цінності на їх формування
і я тут трошки також не згодна з тим що
кар'єрний приходить тільки з
випускниками каже про випускників
Працювати треба раніше цінностями з
мотивацією з побуждением с під час
профспіаційної роботи Якщо ми кажемо
змінимо запити до роботидавця дійсно
вони змінюються на це впливає і певна
автоматизація і діду там процес це це
впливає те що зараз
це покоління Ну ви знаєте напевно я не
буду про це казати що є теорія покоління
і роботодавці дуже з цим працюють до
речі з теорем поколінь І що це і
віддалена робота і гнучкі графік і певна
соціальний пакет але ще хотіла би
відзначити від запиту до роботодавців те
що за останні рік напевно з'явилась І що
дуже важливо для молоді саме
можливість розвиватися мати Цей кар'єрне
зростання що є певне навчання і друге що
компанія себе позиціонує як соціальна
відповідальна компанія це робила
дослідження компанії Jo відео і там
досить великий відсоток був саме того що
люди звертають молодь Звертаю увагу яка
це компанія яка вона в суспільстві чи
воно залякав ней репутація бренд
роботодавця скажемо так тому роботодавці
дійсно цим також треба працювати разом з
цими чинниками які впливають на обрання
саме цієї компанії які я сказала раніше
Дякую Так дякую дуже за вашу думку і
дуже її підтримую адже вже має значення
для молоді в тому числі не лише яка
заробітна платня як називається компанія
як виглядає робоче місце а й соціальні
аспекти аспекти відповідальності
компанії перед співробітниками перед
країною світу ми так далі тому так це
також стає важливим повністю підтримую
Ну і Насправді обожнюю коли в форматі
панельної дискусії дійсно є елементи
дискусії коли спікери між собою
дискутують Тому це дійсно цікаво І
власне Анастасія пані Анастасію з
кар'єрхаб чуєте нас
долучитися і ще раз давайте представлю
Анастасія Вона є координатикою напрямку
кар'єрного консультування кар'єр-хаб
громадської організації центр розвитку
корпоративного соціальної
відповідальності і отже яка ваша думка
щодо того як еволюціонують пріоритети
молоді
говорила пані Людмила починала говорити
з того що Хто і як формує цей запит або
взагалі як він формується так тобто
грубо кажучи звідки молодь бере
розуміння того що саме це мій запит до
роботодавця А цього я там не хочу або не
буду Або туди я не піду і тут в принципі
мені здається що в цьому плані є такою
помічною проста схема але дуже відома
для кар'єрного консультування оця наша
Тріада хочу можу треба так Тобто там де
ми розуміємо що в принципі по суті на
формування запиту і на усвідомлення
цього запиту як мінімум Ну так глобально
впливають три фактори мої бажання Та то
що я хочу Як я себе в ідеалі бачу що я
вмію або що я потенційно буду вміти якщо
завершу там ту чи іншу спеціальність
наприклад Так і що фактично потрібно
ринку праці тобто що потрібно
роботодавцю Ну да як в основному гравцю
цього ринку праці і тут насправді от я
Саме тут бачу величезну задачу і центрів
кар'єри І абсолютно погоджуюсь тим що і
профорієнтаційної системи при тому
профорієнтаційної системи шкільної тому
що Ну насправді нам буде дуже складно
студенту першого курсу університету або
там профтехнічного закладу довести що
щось там якось Мабуть він обрав не так
або щось з цим зробити тоді ми маємо або
починати спочатку
переорієнтація і тоді взагалі не
зрозуміло навіщо Людина втратила умовно
кажучи певну кількість свого часу і
свого є тією самою мотивацією так от і
так далі Тобто ми по суті будемо
перероблювати роботу в якийсь відсоток
якщо ви включаємось на цьому етапі якщо
ми включаємося на етапі шкільної
профорієнтації ранньої профорієнтації
особливо якщо це будуть профорієнтаційні
проєкти наприклад коли дитина підліток
може спробувати так не просто там пройти
тест або послухати а спробувати
приміряти цю професію на себе тоді
Звичайно все буде більш продуктивно І
абсолютно підтримую тезу про те що якщо
ми говоримо про діяльність центрів
кар'єри на всіх рівнях на рівні школи на
рівні закладу про технічної освіти на
рівні університету то ми маємо говорити
про системну діяльність при тому в
ідеалі про системну діяльність яка
перетікає одна в одну так тобто щоб це
не було так що в школі в нас
відбувається щось одне в проце у нас
відбувається щось інше А в університеті
вона взагалі відбувається щось по
принципу Я художник Я так бачу І от я
тут побудував таку систему тому вона в
мене буде такою от тому що інакше Якщо
ці штуки ніде не перетинаються то по
суті про яке формування запиту як таке
ми можемо говорити Так ми це буде щось
ну дуже таке розгалужене дуже
незрозуміле і дуже аморфне по природі
своїх і щось таке що кудись тече як ото
знаєте желе яке там
що щось з ним не те сталося от тому Ну
для мене це виглядає якось так якщо
говорити більш конкретно про запити від
молоді які ми зараз бачимо то тут такий
от особливо в наших сьогоднішніх воєнних
умовах Та є певний конфлікт тому що з
одного боку є вся ота історія дійсно з
теорією поколінь з тим що молодь Ну
скажімо не можу сказати стала більш
суб'єктною на ринку праці Але хотіла би
себе такою відчувати Скажімо так тобто
ніби як молодь стає активним гравцем
молодь розуміє що спів на це не про
монолог там де мене
запитують роботодавець Так молодь
починає розуміти що це про діалог
наприклад і про те що по суті
роботодавця також можна і треба ставити
питання І якісь свої вимоги і ну умовно
перевіряти в хорошому сенсі цього
роботодавця та на те відповідає він цим
вимогам чи ні але в іншого боку ми все
одно зараз бачимо що е-е
війна нам задає тенденцію того що ринок
праці переходить в площину в площину
ринку праці роботодавця тому що на ринку
праці величезна кількість так званих
поверхваліфайт спеціалістів так
спеціалістів які вже є ну якби готовими
до включення яких не потрібно до навчати
яких роботодавця там мінімально потрібно
якось під себе підлаштовувати і під свої
виробничі процеси і звичайно В цьому
плані молоді стає складніше тому що вони
ну по суті це нерівна конкуренція
трошечки так тому що їм доводиться
конкурувати з великою кількістю дуже
сертифікованих людей і тут знову ж таки
для мене це Точка входу діяльності
центрів кар'єри так які можуть в
принципі підтримувати молодь які можуть
наприклад співпрацювати за асоціаціями
асоціаціями випускників Перепрошую які
при цьому можуть самі вже бути
роботодавцями так і які можуть
показувати оцей приклад того як можна в
цих умовах невизначеності
адаптуватись і ну фактично все ж таки
бути активним гравцем ринку праці і так
далі але цей Фактор саме Фактор війни те
що ми бачимо ми зараз ну він дуже
впливає він впливає з тієї точки зору що
складно щось об'єктивно планувати і
молодим людям в тому числі так тому що
все якби величезна величезна
невизначеність яка є у всіх нас в
ситуації ну такого встановлення на ринку
праці Да вона є такою дуже підступною
насправді дуже за вашу думку давайте
перейдемо слово пані Марині з h&m
українці Юджин Яка ваша думка щодо того
як трансформується еволюціонують запити
молоді
усіх колег попередні думки з усім
погоджують
агенції в цьому році і Минулого року
проводили опитування молоді Ми зібрали в
кожному уроці більше ніж тисяча через
пандентів і опитали основні критерії які
вони зараз обирають для того щоб вибрати
майбутнє місце роботи тобто На що вони
звертають увагу дивлячись на роботодавця
і відповідно Хочу поділитися з вами
статистикою основне Зараз на що
звертають увагу Звичайно це якщо це була
міжнародна компанія і продовжує бути
міжнародної кампанії Чи вийшла компанія
з ринку Росії Якщо це міжнародна
компанія Якщо це не міжнародна а лише
українська і в принципі має українське
коріння звертають увагу настільки
компанії підтримує гуманітарно
підтримаємо збройні сили України для
того щоб наблизити перемогу стаж одиниці
факторів також звертають увагу як
компанія комунікує чи вона підтримує
наприклад колег працівників яких
мобілізували через проводять компанії
постійні збори Тому це теж один такий х
бачимо що звертають увагу зараз
кандидати при виборі майбутнього місця
роботи звичайно на першому місці
залишається рівень заробітної плати
графік стажування або майбутнього місця
роботи що можна була можливість
поєднувати навчання і роботу також
кандидати прагну щоб компанії навчала
тобто щоб були можливості подальшого не
лише кар'єрного а професійного розвитку
також якщо це дозволяє нам можливість
працювати віддалена там де це дозволяє
Скажем так і звичайно це офіційне
працевлаштування як один із показників
того що роботодавець є надійним Тому це
теж є одним із факторів на рахунок того
[музика]
що може змінитися в найближчими
майбутньому я б сказала в рамках України
це буде продовжуватися і далі рівень
заробітної плати оскільки знову ж таки в
нас є криза економічна Тому зараз
капітати особливо увагу звертають на
оплату
їх роботи також це буде в подальшому
підтримка компанії
настільки компанії допомагають збройним
силам України настільки Вона має свою
позиціонування як вона комунікує це теж
буде одним із факторів і Третє - це буде
підтримка компанії команди яка вже зараз
працює тобто чи проводяться якісь
психологічні тренінги ці надає компанія
підтримку усім працівників наприклад які
постраждали можливо їх сім'я була
наприклад повітряна тривога сім'я
постраждалих чи підтримує компанія Чи
дає якусь компенсацію чи допомагає
наприклад переїзду переїздом У більш
безпечне місце це теж один із факторів
на що буде звертати увагу в найближчому
майбутньому тобто найближчий рік На мою
думку так Дякую Марина на вашу думку і
давайте як і в першому колі запитання
вже ж почуємо безпосередньо думку самих
закладів так що Вони думають про те як
пріоритети учнів трансформуються так що
буде змінюватися і До чого готуватися
слово надаю пані Наталії з Вінницького
вищого професійного училища у сфері
послуг
технологів І от саме оця еволюція яка
відбувається дату на перший на перший
такий щабеля можу винести саме бажання
працювати рано да тобто вони приходять
на навчання І вони вже бажають йти на
підприємство працювати да тобто раніше
такого не було і в одній з моїх груп був
хлопчик який
розпочав свою роботу Да тобто почав
працювати практично з першого курсу і до
третього курсу Він вже приїхав на
власному авто Тобто це про те як він як
він мотивований наскільки він був і все
ж таки наскільки йому подобалося та
професія і він знайшов саме свого
роботодавця
Хочу зазначити що він першу частину дня
приходив на навчання а другу приходив
працював а далі а далі уже на третьому
курсі є кількість оформити дуальну
освіту Я думаю що колеги з цим знайомі
наступний момент який я теж для себе
визначила от зовсім недавно до мене
прийшов учень каже Наталя Миколаївна
допоможіть мені будь ласка знайти якусь
роботодавця де б я міг би приходити
навіть в суботу неділю там працювати І я
так він каже напрям безкоштовно тобто
Уявіть собі що зараз
наша молодь орієнтується не стільки на
фінансову підтримку не всі звичайно але
на досвід який вони можуть отримати і на
рівень того спеціаліста з яким вони
будуть працювати тобто працювати поруч з
хорошим шеф-кухарем Це дійсно великий
подарунок Тому що ми знаємо зараз
скільки в наш час коштують різноманітні
майстер-класи і навчання кухарів
наступний етап - це
бажання визнання так Вони хотять щоб їх
визнавали і ви знаєте ми буквально
тиждень назад провели тиждень нашого
кулінарного профілю на які на якому було
велика кількість заходів і практично в
кожному заході приймали участь Наші учні
наші діючі учні які поруч з викладачами
і майстрами виробничого навчання
проводили майстер-класи
розповідали там про
ті речі які вони знають в яких вони
обізнані і
наш директорка сказала каже от в нас
тиждень пройшов під таким девізом свої
навчають своїх
наступний момент - це можливість
розвитку та кар'єрного росту да тобто
зараз на це звертають увагу як говорили
попередні спікери це дуже важливо
відчувати що ти можеш рости і бачити оце
світло в кінці тунеля що не все життя ти
будеш займати саме оту робітничу
професію І хочу сказати що теж абсолютно
живий досвід
два рік назад що коли була можливість
нам активно проходити практику Ми
проходили практику на базі рута на
березі Чорного моря і наші
хлопчики працюючи спочатку прийшли
певний період адаптації був але по
завершенню один з учнів став керівником
овочевого цеху да Тобто це можливість
кар'єрного росту він такий був щасливий
що коли ми від'їжджали всім своїм
працівницям а Їх було три Да він зробив
подарунки Але для них це можливість
кар'єрного тесту і звичайно зростає ріст
престижності професій завдяки
різних різним кулінарним програмам зараз
професія кухар вона доволі престижною
стає якісь зміни в найближчому
майбутньому я ще хвилиночку це рівень у
мотивованості Та амбіційності от дійсно
він з'являється далі прояв патріотизму
те про що говорили теж попередні спікери
він вже проявляється і інколи навіть
такий доволі загострений
ріст престижності самої
професійно-технічної освіти зараз в
теперішніх реаліях да Коли все практично
З чим стикаємося це зроблено руками
профтехівця Це надзвичайно класно
волонтерська діяльність
свідомо учні наші здобувачі освіти Вони
працюють саме волонтерами і крім того
всього дякуючи оці волонтерські
діяльності багато хто
формує ранні навики підприємництва ну у
мене все Так дякую дуже за вашу думку
насправді мені дуже багато чого
відгукнулося як також представнику ну
відносно молоді скажемо так А ось але
будемо рухатися саме далі по дискусії І
запрошую до слова пане Олександра власне
учня Яка ваша думка щодо того як же і
волюціонують пріоритети що зараз от з
Musthave Як то кажуть мати роботодавчу
щоб ви хотіли отримати на першому
робочому місці
Справа в тому що сьогодні
молодь сама хоче бути роботодавцем
І в кінечні своїй меті вона
діти навчальних закладів самі вже хочуть
бачать своє майбутнє не в тому що я
пропрацюю до пенсії і потім виходжу на
пенсію розповідає як я працював сьогодні
молодь сама хоче створювати робочі місця
чи добре Це для дітей допитливих дуже
добре це якраз певна мотивація Я працюю
Я хорошо виконую свою роботу Я бачу своє
завдання
Тим паче якщо це керівна посада і я вже
не маю людей якраз мова про Soft Skills
не про те як саме я можу нарізати моркву
чи бараболю А про спілкування у команді
щоб стати шеф-кухарем Мені не потрібно
знати точний час жаркоє картоплі фрі
Мені потрібно розуміти почуття інших
людей їхнє розуміння до цього сьогодні
прагне молодь якщо дитина допитлива - Це
її може далеко далеко завести
якщо дитина не допитлива Я вважаю що це
буде дуже погано
я буду кожен ранок просинатися і думати
чому мені так чому в мене умовно батьки
не бізнесмени не депутати чому мене не
забезпечили Чому я повинен цим займатись
це відповідно впливає на якість роботи
якість роботи неякість життя далі
самооцінка
дуже погані наслідки що може змінитись Я
абсолютно впевнений що після нашої
Перемоги
всі ми так добре видихнемо що більшість
запитань які нас турбують ну саме
турбують як Якісь можливо певні
негаразди вони відійдуть абсолютно на
інший план Ми себе присвячуємо
присвятимо роботі сім'ї друзям Ну і
Прекрасна половина нашої планети собі ще
присвяти час Тому що нас чекає в
майбутньому я думаю що все дуже чудове
та приємно
Дякую Олександре за вашим вмотивованість
насправді і ми рухаємося далі по нашому
запитання як еволюціонують пріоритети
молоді і До чого готуватися і
роботодавцями І власне закладам
професійної і професійно-технічної
освіти Хотів би запросити до слова пані
Ларису та пані Яну з
вищого професійного училища номер 22 чи
чуєте нас
так чуємо
значить що я хочу сказати Шановні колеги
в першу чергу зараз діти хочуть дуже
отримувати гідну заробітну плату
також Хочеться їм звичайно дружній
колектив
відкритий спілкування відчуття комфорту
на робочому місці звичайно щоб
було мінімум начальників так в основному
молодь хоче аби була
вільна мова спі Це вільний так якби
плавний графік гнучкий графік їхньої
роботи хочуть вони також аби було
відрядження за кордон для обміну
досвідом щоб вони могли поділитися своїм
досвідом і отримати досвід від інших так
якби роботодавці
активно в першу чергу щоб роботодавці
активного розвивали усілякі програми аби
ростити майбутніх лідерів по своїй
професії Також потрібно
прагнути молодь повинна прагнути
включатися в роботу і отримувати
реальний досвід і
молоді фахівці вони в першу чергу зараз
готові слухати і переймати практичні
знання навчатися здобувати знання і
навики і розвивати свої професійні
навички
також
студенти
випускники не можуть постійно перебувати
в офісі
влаштовує тобто
є але більшість хоче бути щоб графік був
вільний можливо працювати навіть на
відстані і за це отримувати гроші але
при цьому Ми повинні враховувати щось
Свобода у цьому всьому не повинна пере-
переписати в якісь
також молодь святкує за світовими
трендами вони звичайно що
дуже багато спеціальних мережах і
відразу свою професію підлаштовують так
як би мовити не підлаштовують а
порівнюють і закордонними професіями і
закордонними навиками і їм хочеться
цього І вони готові працювати так би
мовити з трудового є такі звичайні
Біблії аби отримувати тут достойну групу
платну яка є за кордоном Звичайно що є
ті діти які
На жаль митніх канікул від закордон і
там працюють по своїй професії І коли
вони повертаються до країну перше що я
їх не заготовується те що вона дуже
низька заробітна платня хотілося б
звичайно щоб вона була вищою
і я думаю що наші кадри нічим не
відрізнялися від закордонних кадрів а
також в основному діти
готові працювати готові
налаштовані залишатися в своїй країні і
вони все ж таки чекають що в нас в
Україні Все буде добре і буде досить
гідне заробітна плата і літні умови
Дякую дуже колеги за вашу думку важливо
хочу доповнити хтось
тоді колеги щодо підсумовуючи власне
друге запитання щоб я хотів додати знову
ж таки зі свого досвіду з роботи з
нашими здобувачами освіти Ну я тут
повністю підтримую думку колег про те що
ринок більше стає ринком роботодавця та
тобто коли пропозиції мало багато
пошукатів роботи власне він і до плану
масштабного Вторгнення в багатьох
галузях був саме таким але щоб я хотів
додати хотів би ну згадати приклад того
як роботодавців себе поводили коли лише
почалась пандемія так в 20-му році на
початку І коли ми так умовно з нею
виходили 21-му році на початку пандемії
дуже багато роботодавців знову ж таки
прикрили більшість своїх можливостей для
молоді саме тому що знову ж таки
з'явилися на ринку
overwelify спеціалісти так вільні руки
готові руки яких не потрібно до навчати
і не тільки руки і мізки Так але коли
знову ж таки почав з'являтися попит на
дуже різних фахівців в тому 21-му році
тут у житті роботодавці які повністю
такі можливості своїми руками прикрили
вже виявилося не готовими вони вже
мусили десь Шукати тих фахівців різко
шукати так е-е великі ємності і виграли
тут саме ці роботодавці які нехай і
мають його таку певну сміливість певне
прогнозування оптимізм в сторону того що
все станемо кращим не з такі можливості
нехай можливо зробили меншими по обсягам
запит на Молоді але не закрили їх так
продовжували і формати навчання і якісь
можливо стажування працевлаштування
практики і от вони в той в той ситуації
були дуже великому такому значному в
тому числі фінансовому виграші тому тут
хоча ми спілкуємося сьогодні більше з
представниками власне центрів кар'єри
так за освітянами з учнями нашими Але
знову ж таки реально після нашої
Перемоги дуже багато буде потрібно рук а
щоб От такі робочі руки і голови були
звісно І зараз треба працювати
інвестувати саме в молоді Ну і що того
як я отказав що в виступу моєї колеги
дуже багато чого мені викликнулися А
щодо Ну в мене знову ж таки ну мабуть
найважливіше це є почуття От залученості
і важливості своєї справи на робочому
місці тому що ну це те Без чого важко
розуміти сенс окрім заробітної платні -
Це мабуть що ну такий драйвер найбільший
для мене для молоді з якою з ким я
спілкуюся тож це я одним з таких
визначальним факторів А ми колеги
рухаємося далі і
третє наше запитання теж як казала
Людмила про процес Так але теж важливий
процес - це планування професійного
розвитку молоді тож звучить воно Так
плануємо професійний розвиток раз які
особливості кар'єрного консультування є
визначальними в контексті саме про в
техосвіти і давайте тут почнемо Це коло
саме з представників закладів
професійної професійно-технічної освіти
запрошую до слова пані
Добре
Ну що стосується саме особливості
кар'єрного консультування і того що які
плани мають бути я думаю що в основу має
лягти розвиток все-таки Soft Skills це
навиків соціальних які
які зазвичай
професійно-технічної освіти де є в
обмеженій кількості Навіть якщо це
відбувається то так якось упосередковано
тобто
і в першу чергу зрозуміло що має бути
чітка професійна діагностика для того
щоб чітко визначити
Яким шляхом іти і те хочу можу буду про
яке вже згадували і те що потрібно
насправді да от наскільки це потрібно
зараз на ринку праці та професії і
звичайно те що потрібно взагалі те що
буде добре оплачуватися Це теж не мало
важно
розвиток емоційного інтелекту да Тобто
ми говоримо про те що
є дуже гарні спеціалісти
хлопчики і дівчатка з золотими руками
які не можуть просто себе презентувати
вони не можуть вони бояться в мене було
б дуже багато випадків коли приходили От
після наших заходів хлопці і дівчат
запрошували на роботу Вони кажуть Ми не
підемо все ж таки заклад тобто ну
реально вони бояться цього для того щоб
цього не було Це емоційний інтелект
варто активно розвивати і я думаю що це
буде завдання центру кар'єрного росту
дальше розвиток креативного мислення ну
в наш час без креативного мислення дати
той хто вміє креативно мислити отримує
набагато більше ніж той хто цього
мислення не розвиває Я вважаю що дуже
важливо займатися фінансовою грамотністю
це є аспект одне діло заробляти гроші а
інша спра краще
грамотно ними
грамотний їх використовувати
Я думаю що той хлопчик який купив
автомобіль він грамотно використовував
заробляючи кошти
навики діловодства і юридична підтримка
правильно грамота написана резюме
підтримка юристів вона теж має бути в
рамках
[музика]
центру і Я визначила сиділа так бавилася
з цими буквами K і визначила для себе
оцім таких слів які я вважаю Вони теж
повинні бути ключовими а саме в роботі
центру це комунікація колаборація
креативність критичне мислення
конфліктологія командна робота і
компетентність
в мене все дякую за увагу Окей дякую
Дуже за лаконічність за вашу думку Ну і
продовжуємо власне говорити в контексті
нашого запитання щодо того які
особливості кар'єрного консультування
саме для учнів
професійно закладів професійної
професійно-технічної освіти пані Лариса
пані янова вам слово якщо чуєте нас
так
На мою думку в першу чергу для
здобувачів повинна бути психологічна
підтримка Це я вам розповідаю Славському
досвіду
діти бояться після закінчення навчання
ставати на роботу не всі звичайно але в
більшості бояться немає як ніхто їх
сміливості той впевненості Я служу з
власного досвіду з досвіду перукаря тому
що в першу чергу коли закінчують ідуть
на роботу в них
бояз того що немає досвіду в роботі так
як на мене будуть реагувати клієнти як
мені спілкуватися з клієнтами тому в
першу чергу з свого власного досвіду я
розповідаю їм свій особистий свій
власний досвід з чого я починала і як я
рухалась помаленьку помаленьку вперед
олій професії Я рахую що потрібно
додавати дітям впевненості розповідала
про їхню професію і обов'язково
організовувати зустріч випускників аби
випускники могли розповісти із свого
власного досвіду яким чином вони
рухалися вперед обов'язково потрібно
налаштовувати дітей що всі люди різні і
Ми повинні сприймати всіх людей так не
повинні з ними спілкуватися Ми повинні
входити в їх точку зору розмовляти з
людьми Не конфліктувати це в будь-якій
професії Тому що якщо я не буду перші
конфлікт і уже він у вашій у вашому
кар'єрному прості тому Я рахую що
психологічна підтримка і зустріч з
випускниками це так якби основна
складова кар'є
зростання цієї підготовка так якби
фундаментальна для
судів в подальшому взагалі для робочої
осіб дякую
Окей дякую рухаємося далі Ну і власне
пане Олександре запитання
ви обрали свій фах от таким як він є Так
і що в контексті саме вашого фаху саме
вашого профілю вам би хотілося в форматі
кар'єрного консультування утримувати які
особливості ви могли визначити
для мене
девізом взагалі життя роботи стали такі
слова приймають на роботу за професійні
якості
звільняють з роботи за особистісні
якраз мова йде про розвиток м'яких
навичок це щось типу вчора на роботі
шукали справедливість Сьогодні ми
шукаємо роботу
з приводу кар'єрного консультування що
було б добре хочу ще трішечки розказати
як ми впроваджуємо те про що розповідала
пані Наталія
насправді можна сказати з неї це і
почалося Це був урок організація В чому
суть уявіть Діти прийшли на уроки в чаті
зошити щоденники ми спробували ми
спробували подати їм трішечки іншої
інформації
параорганізація була подана
з підручниками і з цікавими оповідями і
розповідями в усякому разі така була
мета тепер уявіть вчорашні вчорашні
11-класники підходять і запитують за
книги після цього де їх взяти скільки
коштує як записати сюди бібліотеку ну
особисто для мене це прям перемога
Капець
до прикладу критичне мислення як його
розвинути
сунзи Мистецтво війни там є цитата герой
- це не той хто здобув 100 перемог у 100
битвах геройство - це здобути військо
антагоніста взагалі без боротьби Давайте
подумаємо про що це І як це зробити це
просто клас далі що ми почали робити
Справа в тому ми це намагаємось робити
коли є урок з подібною темою щоб не
навантажувати ще після уроків ще там
Приходьте урок подібна тема робимо такий
самий невеличкий виступ головне
зацікавити зрозумілою мовою
діти реально запитують були ще навіть
нас група виходить перше після дев'ятого
класу пол етман праця Теорія брехні є
серіал такий Там хайлайтман головний
герой А є саме теоретик Як ви брехня це
завжди фантазія правда це завжди спогад
там експерименти невеликі проводили з
вегетативною нервовою системою дітям
цікаво тепер уявіть ще один плюс мало
того що вони вже цікавляться не тільки
як зачіску вірно зробити вони ще
цікавляться якраз цим розвитком
спілкування розуміння людей розуміння
один одного і ще один чудовий побічний
ефект
замість того щоб ввечері
займатись не дуже хорошими справами
дитина буде сидіти і читати книжку ну це
просто клас Так ми намагаємось ніби як
Обережно не нав'язливо
нав'язувати цей розвиток софт скілів
всі діти абсолютно хочуть до себе уваги
стосовно кар'єрного консультування
кожному було приємно
позитивне підкріплення невелике навіть
коли в дитини не виходить Щось Слухай я
бачу твої старання в тебе буде добре ти
впораєшся
клас все перестає прямо рук якщо дитина
переживала чи там биться що пальці
поріже якщо це мова про кухню все клас
зовсім інша дитина як мені здається
просто потрібно дати шанс А оці наші
замудрості їх подавати не нав'язливої в
цікавому форматі справді як дітям у
вигляді гри
Дякую дуже Олександр за вашу думку що ж
ми послухали безпосередньо тих хто
навчається тих хто навчає так а тепер
давайте перейдемо до наших експертів
повторю про всіх випадках питання
звучить воно Так плануємо професійний
розвиток разом Які особливості
кар'єрного консультування є найбільш
означальними в контексті роботи
закладами професійної
професійно-технічної освіти запрошую до
слова пані Анастасію з кар'єр хап
та Дякую я би тут насправді коли ми
говоримо про кар'єрне консультування
особливо про технічну освіти я би тут
почала знову ж таки з того що це має
бути системна історія я однозначно
згодна з колегами що так там мають бути
софт скіли але воно має бути
вбалансоване так і прив'язане тобто
вбудоване в сам процес навчання і тут я
би насправді до чого звернулася точно
звернулася до важливості розуміння зміни
позиції
викладача і кар'єрного консультанта тому
що найчастіше так в закладах про
технічну освіти кар'єрним
консультуванням займаються ті самі
викладачі або майстри виробничого
навчання просто які пройшли якийсь
додатковий курс так чи додаткове
навчання і цікавляться цією темою ну або
ж там наприклад хтось з представників
адміністрації і тут мені здається що
всім нам важливо розуміти що якщо ми
говоримо про кар'єрне консультування
учнів то ми швидше говоримо про позицію
менторства
пропозицію так викладання і стану
позицію консультанта тому тут мені
здається що основне це саме відбудова
отих стосунків стосунків підтримки
стосунків того що людина яка виступає в
ролі консультанта Так вона має певну
експертизу але вона є не критиком а саме
людиною яка може допомогти може провести
та іншу людину тобто фактично учня по
його шляху і звичайно ж однозначно це
питання Soft скілів в плані я би навіть
сказала і Soft скілів і певною такою
психологічною компетентності тому що
зараз якщо ми говоримо про учнів про
техосвіти то ми розуміємо що парадигма
роботи на виробництві
змінюється парадигмою роботи замовником
здебільшого так і це вже про психологію
це вже про вміння подати себе це вміння
про вміння налагодити контакт тобто в
насправді випускників все менше і менше
шансів прийти просто кудись на
виробництво так і залишитися там
працювати Тому що виробництва фактично
стає менше як такого і в нашими
останніми тенденціями на жальними це
також бачимо і це говорить про те що
учням потрібно буде самостійно собі
шукати клієнтів так налагоджувати з ними
зв'язок і виходити саме в площину роботи
в клієнтом і просування своїх послуг
Саме тут звичайно софт скіли і саме
емоційна психологічна компетентність
вони виступають на перший план Ну і плюс
То про що вже говорили колеги в
кар'єрному консультуванні особливо якщо
ми говоримо там про кар'єрний коучинг
так дійсно багато інструментів які
можуть
додати впевненості власне
коучингменторство - це про оце
формування самооцінки професійної так і
про формування розуміння того що
здобувши певну освіту я можу бути
елементну здатним спеціалістом тому що
так я маю певні обмеження Можливо так
професійні в тому числі але я добре знаю
свої сильні сторони і можу на них
втратитись і от для мене якщо там де
звертатися до тебе пані Людмили щоб все
ж таки говорити більше про Результат то
для мене отут в результаті скажімо
кар'єрного консультування саме в цьому
сегменті одним з його результатів має
стати розуміння того що випускник або
учень профтехосвіти розуміє свої сильні
сторони і вміє на них спиратись так
тобто він вміє не просто розуміти те що
мене там навчили не знаю конструювати
щось або там робити зачіски або ще щось
інше от а чітке розуміння Які мої сильні
сторони в собтах в Харт навичках і як я
можу на це впиратися як я можу це
презентувати тому роботодавцю на ринку
праці Так дякую дуже за вашу думку
Анастасії повністю її підтримує
погоджуюся я б навіть ще додав Що додати
оцього усвідомлення що учень випускник
має вже певний факт І це його велика
перевага насправді перед людьми які ще
Ну наприклад в тому ж віці можна кажучи
ще не мають фаху і це вже є
конкурентноздатність це я перевага це
готовність працювати так і розвивати
себе як фахівця професіонала давайте
рухатися далі І до слова запрошую пані
Марину з організації Юджин
Дякую колеги Я підтримую на рахунок того
в вас Роман і вас Анастасії на рахунок
того що якраз те що вони вже мають
професійну освіту в них є розвинуті так
звані харківські ви тому вони є
конкурентноздатними в порівнянні з
іншими кандидатами їх віку щоб я
рекомендувала додати навчання якомога
максимум розвивати про це вже сьогодні
говорили Але хотіла підтримати навички
комунікації навички презентації себе
тому що на жаль Якщо говорити про
навички комунікації бояться
перетелефонувати бояться говорити
бояться
Вибачте спілкуватися з незнайомими
людьми бояться вести переговори бояться
продавати себе скажемо так Якщо говорити
про навички ораторського мистецтва тут
як презентувати себе як правильно себе
подати коли ти спілкуєшся з незнайомими
людьми коли ти приходиш до роботодавця
коли ти приходиш співбесіду коли ти
проходиш телефонну співбесіду коли тобі
на певну вакантію певну позицію зараз я
бачу що дійсно учні молоді дуже складно
перетелефонувати Якщо ти не знаєш людину
Їм краще написати це дочекатися
відповіді якщо не дочекайте відповіді
нагадати про це але якомога далі
витягувати той момент щоб не
телефонувати або взагалі не
перетелефонувати Тому це навичка
комунікації з незнайомими людьми дійсно
стоїть досить гостро і тому я б
рекомендувала робити на цьому акцент Як
спілкуватися з незнайомими як
презентувати себе як позиціонувати себе
як правильно розповісти про себе під час
співбесіди з рекрутаром або директором
який проводиться співбесіду
Так дякую дуже Марина за вашу думку і
продовжуємо нашу дискусію наше
спілкування Я запрошую до слова пані
людмило з федерації роботодавців України
і Також я думаю після відповіді на
запитання ви можете поділитися слайдами
які готували
так
якщо ви не проти я хотіла би зараз
тому що треба бути
[музика]
людмило якщо чуєте нас то ви трошки
зависли
колеги чи є Людмила на зв'язку зараз
добре Можливо Людмила перепідключається
і знову ж таки реалії такі як є технічні
моменти трапляються колеги можливо мають
запитання в контексті того що ми от
проговорили можемо зараз розглянути
о Людмила бачу повернулася чуєте нас
Окей поки що не чуєте колеги якщо хтось
має запитання то підніміть будь ласка
руку і наші спікери на зв'язку в онлайні
на зв'язку наживо будемо відповідати на
ваші запитання
Ну і Загалом до математики панелі
дискусії і конкретно до того запитання
над чим ми ще працюємо От коли я
проводжу тренінги Мої колеги теж ми
обов'язково питаємо от які ну ваші є і
проблеми і пріоритети в роботі і ще один
пріоритет про який згадує згадують
колеги так які ну повністю на поверхні
але все ж таки важливо які варто
опрацьовувати це важливість донести те
що от можна і варто і потрібно працювати
саме в Україні Так тому що контекст
такий що люди шукають роботу за кордоном
шукають можливості виїхати то бо там
більше плаття так Хтось думає що там
краще живеться Так але поки там люди не
стикаються з реаліями воно вони того по
факту не можуть сказати відчути І от щоб
наші фахівці залишалися з нами це є теж
от комплексна велика робота як і
роботодавців щоб створити зі своєї
сторони конкурентно здасть на робоче
місце так назвемо це робота назвами для
того щоб мотивувати учнів розказувати
чому наступне просто що треба працювати
в Україні а чому треба працювати в
Україні в тому місті на той підприємстві
так і це теж є велика робота і закладів
вищої при закладів професійної освіти
професійно-технічної і роботодавців
зокрема ну і звісно саме учнів робота на
своєму мотивацією для чого вони пішли на
той чи інший фах Ось і які їх пріоритети
перспективи а шановні спікери хто з нами
в онлайні Можливо у вас є доповнення
щодо тематики дискусії нашої в цілому
Нагадую що це є Кар'єрна консультування
його виклики сьогодення пріоритети на
найближче майбутнє Можливо хтось ще хоче
чимось поділитися своїм досвідом
знаннями проблематикою зараз маємо
трошки на цей час
так давайте
багато говорили але ми маємо дійсно
певні напрацювання і впродовж
декількох років в рамках своїх уроків І
взагалі в рамках різних заходів Ми
запрошуємо наших
успішних випускників і коли я
спостерігаю за реакцією своїх учнів
здобуваючи освіти
то доволі часто
це стає таким дуже крутим мотиваційним
поштовхом до того щоб вони почали
навчатися і зовсім по-іншому ставитись
до професії і ви знаєте дуже дивна була
така зустріч коли є хлопчики які сидять
на останніх партах і зазвичай їм нічого
не цікаво і коли учень який був нашим
випускником точніше є випускником зараз
він на передові
розповідав про свою історію успіху про
те що він був одним з тих хто сидів на
останніх партах і потім він озвучив свою
заробітну плату то хлопці проснулися
тому і в тейму В той момент я зрозуміла
наскільки важливо взагалі давати
можливість отакої комунікації про це
говорили сьогодні не один раз
комунікації між вже діючими працівниками
тими хто чогось досягли і тими хто
тільки навчається в професії
і це реально дає дуже класні результати
тому якщо комусь потрібно такий досвід
використовуєте
Так дякую дуже за вашу думку і не
нагадую друзі що от під час наших перерв
можна знову ж таки підійти до нашої
експертів проконсультуватися поділитися
власним досвідом тому що це ну знову ж
таки це не просто одна із можливостей -
це одна із цілей наших зустрітися саме
наживо щоб цим досвідом обмінятися а
бачу що до нас повернулися пані Людмила
Отже знову ж таки два слова для
відповіді на запитання дискусії і ваша
коротка презентація
Так Дуже дякую колеги дійсно
інтернет-зв'язок є не дуже стійкі я
хотіла трохи додати чуєте мене колеги
я хотіла трохи додати про що ми казали
про саме кар'єрне консультування так то
треба розуміти знову ж таки хто клієнт
цієї роботи для чого це проводиться
Кар'єрна констатування і треба починати
з того з кінця як завжди кажу
Навіщо куди піде молода людина працювати
Яка робота і звідки ми отримуємо цю
інформацію ну по-перше аналіз Праці а
по-друге це знання про те які є
технології які підприємства займаються
роботою з молоддю і тут в мене до вас
пропозиція можливо зробити треба спільно
з кар'єрними центрами таку візуалізацію
перелік компаній які
пропонують певні проекти для молоді
наприклад зараз компанія Кернел - Це
агрокомпанія вона активізувала свій в
університет агромолод агроуніверситет і
займається саме це студенти зі
студентами і багато інших компаній Тому
давай
зробимо разом Федерація роботодавців
центр кар'єри такий перелік компаній
яким займаються спільно з молоддю є
проекти для молоді і може це на на самом
напевно якусь віртуальну таку мапу щоб
людина могла зайти молода людина з
мобільного додатку подивитися яка це
компанія яким проєкти які можливості для
неї є Тоді це буде одним із Хай
невеличких але наше таких результатах
тому що до речі компанії дуже багато
пропонують ідеальну форму навчання І
коли це ти її застосовуєш Тоді не буває
страху про що сьогодні казали що є
певний страх як спілкуватися яка моя
буде робота яка перша робоче місце якими
ми наставник ментор коли дуальна форма
це на мій погляд найефективніша зараз
форма взаємодії і тоді немає вже страху
тому що ти бачив колектив Ти бачив
наставника Ти бачив
свою бригаду або там інше робоче місце
або віддали на робоче місце це може за
телефоном і ти вже розумієш і графік
роботи і якщо до тебе тому будь ласка і
такі компанії також є і треба знати про
це які компанії пропонують певні такі
тренінги ведення в професій також чимало
які компанії навчають наставники я скажу
Шановні колеги Що зараз від компанії
великі попит запит на навчання
наставників І ми це робимо разом з
іншими партнерами і щоб ви розуміли це
наставники це ті які навчають не тільки
ніхто на практику але і своїх
працівників молодих не молодих які при
навчаються тому робіть роботодавець тоже
зацікавлений в тому щоб робота з людьми
з людським капіталом з персоналом як
кажуть іноді була ефективною щоб
навчання було ефективно тому що це
впливає на лояльність на відношення на
розвиток на
перенавчання на нові навички тому Зараз
дуже великі запит на дійсно на навчання
наставників менторів компаніях і ми
зараз зібрали першу групу таку спільно з
язиком я не ма допомоги навіть усіх
бажаючих у цю групу записати ми будемо
продовжувати і нові групи відкривати
тому що дуже великі кількість і Ви також
можете знати ці компанії центр кар'єри
де приділяють увагу наставництва
мендерство
і як долучитися до спільних тих груп
навчання щоб не бути в одному середовищі
тому що на рішенням часто впливає
середовище друзі батьки наставники
колеги колектив там інший просто група
товариші Як то кажуть тому що це дуже
важливо Давайте зробимо такий перелік
таких пропозицій можливості для молоді і
взаємодії з молоді от це таке що я
хотіла сказати як наш результат можливо
і пропозицію і дуже
Людмила трохи знайти
покажу деякі слайди які До речі саме
бачите мене на екрані
і зараз на слайді бачити також
слайди чи ні от зараз побачимо вже
бачимо таржиться
Давайте виведемо тоді
все чудово так я так добре колеги я ще
певним чином не передивилася дуже
коротко інформація І звісно ми
домовлялися Ми зі спікерами але бачите
що робиться на екрані знову ринок
роботодавця про це казали дійсно
практичні відповідності Я дуже коротко
сказала про те що є підставою поштовхом
для кар'єрно-консультування наявна
інформація ринок праці треба аналізувати
брат цю інформацію обов'язково Тому що і
потім обов'язково дуже запрошую закладу
освіти до співпраці з роботодавцями щодо
професійних стандартів саме сьогодні
саме у цей час 17 червня коли закон 2179
визначив що професійний документ з точки
зору вимог до людини на робочому місці І
потім іде інший документи кваліфікаційна
характеристика якщо немає стандарту
професійний стандарт це є те що є
основою для кар'єрного консультування
там є знання
уміння навички компетенції
із них потім необхідно змістити
професійного навчання тому будь ласка
закладу освіти колеги приєднані до цієї
роботи і треба навчати
зараз дійсно потребує ринок
щодо компетенції дуже багато Сьогодні
було про компетенції і
бачити Я на екрані тут є і інформація
щодо дослідження проект-хаус але є
інформація наша внутрішнє дослідження
Побачити які компетенції
було затримано у роботодавців з робочих
Людмила якщо чуєте нас
так можна зробити фото слайдів якраз
маємо для того нагоду
Людмила якщо чуєте нас Ми вас поки що
тимчасово не чуємо
На жаль випала Людмила Окей Ну давайте
все-таки дочекаємося можливо Людмили
вдасться перепідключитися до конференції
можливо наразі виникли які запитання
готові їх покрити Ну і поки така трошки
невеличка технічна пауза після
завершення дискусії Шановні колеги на
нас очікує приємна сподіванка яка
вказана важить це обід Так є Нагадую що
можна з організаторами з моїми колегами
от тоді нам би щось хочу сказати так ні
Окей та вирішити всі організаційні
питання компенсації і так далі тому
давайте не відкладати це до кінця заходу
але вирішуємо за свої питання смачно
поїмо І після того на нас чекає блок
саме практичної роботи це є аборт кафе А
де ми
ага де ми в
випадковому порядку розподілимося на три
групи які працюватимуть на своєму
запитанні про формат Я звісно розкажу
Але з приводу того як давайте уже Мабуть
що вийду щоб не з місця
так от про формат як ми
розподілимося по цим самим групам у
кожного учасника на бейджику є такі
Можливо трошки дивні рисочки чорним
маркером представлені зверху з однієї зі
сторін вони в нас двосторонні можете
переглянути у вас на бейджику є такі
рисочки якщо немає то ви Підійдіть я
поставлю І от рисочок таких на кожному з
бейджику знаходиться від однієї до трьох
всі знайшли є хтось хто не знайшов
рисочку
якщо не знайшли листочку підніміть ручку
А всі знайшли рисочки І от
так Давайте дамо можливість їм знайти
рисочку так
Да тіка- цікаве таке заняття
ми для студентів за навчання таких
заходів смайлики клеїмо на стільці Ну
тут рисочки завжди такі інтерактивчик
так от знайшли рисочки на своїх
бейджиках і Отже якщо у вас одна рисочка
це означає що ви знаходитесь перші групи
на обіді можете знайти своїх
одногрупників для даної сесії перша
група працюватиме за столом ось тут
тобто після обіду ви повертаєтесь і там
будуть трошки переміщені стільці
переходите за цей стіл вибираєте зручне
собі місця а друга група дві рисочки на
бейджику а розташовуються ось тут другий
стіл так не техніки а от другий стіл
який тут стоїть це є друга група так
само займаєте там місця третя група
працюватиме Ось у цій зоні так тобто
якщо у вас три рисочки на бейджику Так
розміщуєтеся тут але насправді під час
word-кафе ми всі перемістимося Тобто всі
три групи проти ці три столи А і
розглянуть всі є три оголошення питання
знову ж таки якщо ви поки що ще не брали
участь в такому форматі я детально
розкажу після обіду що саме треба буде
зробити Але основне - це одразу як ми
поїмо знову ж таки підживемо наші власні
батарейки павербанки як ми це назвемо
Одразу розподілитися по групам тобто
коли ми зараз будемо йти на обід ви будь
ласка речі свої забирайте Так бо стільці
мусимо перемістити і повертаєтесь вже за
той стіл поки що давайте не вставати А
так а повертаєтесь після обіду за той
стіл за яким
А час повернення Да можна будь ласка
програмку Дякую дуже Да ми рухаємося по
розкладу Отже о 14:20 о 14:20
зустрічаємося вже тут кожен за своїм
столом Я дуже дякую нашим спікерам
експертам хто був з нами на панельний
дискусії навіть
що що
А є У пані Сніжани коментар коли Давайте
тоді трошки посадимо
Окей тоді вже після обіду ще разок
зустрінемось почуємось Бажаю всім
смачного і до зустрічі за 40 хвилин тут
Дякую дуже нашим спікерам панельної
дискусії